Und damit herzlich willkommen zum 243. Chaos Radio Live aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11, wo ihr, falls ihr das im Stream hört und in der Nähe seid, noch vorbeikommen könnt. Wir sitzen hier auf bequemen Sesseln und Sofas und wollen heute über Daten, Journalismus und Open Data sprechen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ich spreche in Mikrofon und werde versuchen, das in den nächsten zwei Stunden so zu tun, dass man grob versteht, worum es hier geht. Und zu Gast sind heute Leute, die einen Beruf haben, der mit Daten anfängt, dann kommt irgendwas anderes. Wir hätten hier zum Beispiel Arne Semsrott, würde ich mal sagen Datenaktivist. Dann Kira Schacht, Datenjournalistin. Und Michael Kreil, Datenwissenschaftler.
Passt.
So und wir wollen heute darüber reden, was es für Daten gibt und was man damit für Dinge einstellen kann, aber schon wirklich konzentriert auf diesen Bereich. Präsentationen für eine breitere Öffentlichkeit, was ihr davon haben kann. Und normalerweise fangen wir so Chaosradios oft beim Urschleim an und arbeiten uns dann langsam vor Ort zu den aktuellen Geschehnissen. Wir könnten jetzt zum Beispiel auch kurz sagen, ja so Open Data Sendung hatten wir schon. 2011 gibt es nichts mehr Neues. Vielleicht doch, doch. Kommen wir auch noch zu. Ich möchte aber heute tatsächlich anfangen mit den schönen Sachen, den bunten Sachen und würde jetzt gerne als allererstes von euch wissen, bevor wir über die ganzen Hintergründe und vielleicht auch Techniken sprechen, was so das eine Projekt ist, wenn ihr gefragt werdet, dieses Datendings, was ihr da macht. Sagt doch mal, was da cool ist, bei rumkommt. Ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wozu das gut sein soll. Also quasi euer Vorzeigeprojekt, Datenjournalismus, Datenbearbeitung, Datenpräsentationen, wo ihr was Geiles geschaffen habt. Und dass ihr aber auch sozusagen glaubt. Wer will anfangen? Wer hat das Beste? Wer hat das Schönste?
Das Schönste, weil ja, sehr, sehr, sehr schön, glaube ich, ist kleineanfragen.de, ein Projekt der Open Knowledge Foundation, ursprünglich gestartet von Maximilian Richt, das ganz schön viele Aspekte von Open Data in sich vereint. Kleine Anfragen sammelt alle kleinen Anfragen von allen Parlamenten in Deutschland, von den Landesparlamenten und dem Bundestag, auf einer Seite zentral. Und das ist eine Wahnsinnswissensdatenbank, weil da alle Anfragen von Parlamentariern an die Regierung und alle Antworten darauf versammelt sind. Und man würde ja denken, ja, das ist ja eh alles schon offen. Was hat denn das mit Open Data zu tun?
Was ist denn eine Anfrage? Also ich mein, das ist anscheinend sozusagen ein politisches Konstrukt. Ich dachte jetzt erst mal, warte, du bist ja von Frag den Staat. Und da geht es ja darum, dass ich als Bürger hingehen kann und sagen kann, also lieber Staat, beantworte mir noch mal bitte folgende Frage. Und dann kümmert ihr euch quasi darum, dass das irgendwie auch passiert. Oder bietet zumindest eine Plattform dafür, dass man sich darum kümmern kann, dass das passiert. Aber diese Anfragen ist ja was anderes.
Ja, das sind nicht einfach nur irgendwelche Bürger, das sind nämlich die Parlamentarier. Und die haben ein verfassungsmäßiges Recht, alle möglichen Infos vom Staat zu bekommen. Das geht teilweise dann noch weiter als nach diesem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und das sieht in der Regel so aus, dass zum Beispiel eine Abgeordnete, die kleine Anfrage macht zum Thema NSU. So, was ist der Zusammenhang zwischen dem Verfassungsschutz in diesem Bundesland und dem NSU? Und dann sind das 20 Fragen, die dann in einer kleinen Anfrage an die Regierung gestellt werden. Und die Regierung muss dann darauf antworten. Und das sind dann in der Regel lange Antwortlisten, die veröffentlicht werden müssen im Internet vom Parlament. Die dann aber veröffentlicht werden, teilweise als ausgedrucktes und wieder eingescanntes PDF. Oder in einer Form auf bundestag.de, dass es zwar da ist, aber mit einer Suchfunktion, die man nicht bedienen kann. Das heißt, es ist zwar da, aber man findet es nicht. Und kleine Anfragen sammelt all diese kleinen Anfragen, wirklich super interessantes Zeug zentral aus allen Landesparlamenten und aus dem Bundestag und stellt zentral zur Verfügung. Das kann man dann durchsuchen. Das heißt, wenn ich da jetzt NSU suche, zum Beispiel sehe ich nicht nur die Anfragen aus Thüringen, sondern auch aus Sachsen dazu, aus dem Bundestag und kann die alle zentral durchsuchen, habe eine Abonnierungsfunktion dazu, kann mir das alles runterladen. Nicht nur als PDF, sondern auch als TXT, als JSON. Das heißt, ich kann damit dann auch noch...
Man hat da Maschinenlisten-Text.
Genau.
Du hast gerade gesagt, da werden Dinge ausgedruckt und dann eingeschrieben. Da hat man ja Bilder, die man zum Beispiel nicht nach Texten durchsuchen, also nach Wörtern.
Genau, und machen es dann zugänglich für viel mehr Menschen. Also, weil so eine Maschinenlesbarkeit zum Beispiel dann auch bedeutet, dass man das barrierefrei gestalten kann. Also, wenn ich ein eingescanntes PDF habe, dann ist das erst mal ein Bild, da kann der Computer nicht mit viel anfangen. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Sehbehinderung habe, dann bin ich darauf angewiesen, vielleicht in manchen Fällen, dass der Computer mir das vorliest. Kann er nicht bei einem Bild, kann er aber, wenn es maschinenlesbar ist. Und man würde ja denken, dass die Parlamente dafür sorgen, dass so zentrale, wichtige Dokumente der Demokratie eigentlich schon so verfügbar sind, sind sie aber nicht unbedingt. Und das macht kleine Anfragen automatisiert. Und deswegen finde ich das großartig.
Also dein Lieblingsprojekt ist ein Projekt, in dem verteilte, aber für unsere Gesellschaft wichtige Informationen zusammengetragen und dann so präsentiert werden, dass sie da rankommt.
Genau. Und jetzt kann man zum Beispiel die Arbeit der AfD in den Landesparlamenten endlich mal analysieren, weil das auf dieser Plattform zentral da ist. Und das könnte man sonst kaum machen.
Also ehrlich gesagt wünsche ich, dazu wäre es nie gekommen. Aber vielleicht ist das dann besser als gar nichts.
Das ist nicht die Schuld von Kleine Anfragen.de.
Okay, das heißt aber, das ist aber auch etwas, da muss ich hingehen und schon ein Interesse haben. Also das ist ein Projekt, was es ermöglicht, wenn ich schon ein Interesse habe, das dann dort nachzuverfolgen. Und das macht es mir dann einfacher, das überhaupt zu machen.
Du kannst auch einfach auf Kleine Anfragen.de gehen und mal rumgucken und dann wird schon irgendwas dich interessieren. Aber ja, im Prinzip natürlich.
Genau, es ist ein zur Verfügung Stellung. Es ist aber nicht, dass ihr eine Aufarbeitung macht und sagt, hier, das sind so die geilen Sachen, die gerade...
Nee, genau, es ist die Möglichkeit, dass Leute damit dann was machen.
Okay, Kira, du bist bei, wie heißt das? Journal Code. Was ist das? Oder anders gefragt. Das hast du ja gesagt, und wenn man nicht fragt, woher kommst du, daher ist das Geizprojekt, von dem du uns gleich erzählen wirst, von dort?
Von Journal Code, meinst du? Wir machen mit Journal Code vor allem momentan Workshops und Vorträge über Datenjournalismus. Das heißt, es ist kein Projekt von Journal Code. Ich habe mir aber eins überlegt, da hat auch noch ein anderer Journal Coder mitgearbeitet. Und zwar, also ich bin ja Journalistin, erst mal übrigens groß erfrieden von kleineanfragen.de, ist ein tolles Recherchetool auch für Journalisten. Und ich habe mir mal ausgesucht, das erste größere Datenprojekt, was ich gemacht habe zusammen mit der Rheinischen Post. Da ist nämlich unser Designer bei Journal Code, Phil Ning, arbeitet bei der Rheinischen Post. Und mit dem und Kollegen zusammen haben wir analysiert, woher die Düsseldorfer kommen. Aus Düsseldorf. Genau, aber einige von denen sind vielleicht nicht in Düsseldorf geboren. Einige kommen vielleicht aus Köln. Einige vielleicht sogar noch abgefahren. Einige vielleicht sogar von noch weiter her, aus der ganzen Welt. Und da gab es einen offenen Datensatz von der Stadt, wo eben diese Geburtsorte drin sind. Das heißt, du hast einen Ort und da steht dann drin, 500 Düsseldorfer kommen aus dem Ort XY. Und das haben wir auf eine lustige Karte gepackt. Und das heißt, du kannst jetzt deinen Geburtsort eingeben und nachschauen, hey, wie viele Leute, die jetzt in Düsseldorf wurden, kommen eigentlich daher. Und das zeigt halt so ein bisschen die Multikulturalität, schwieriges Wort, der Stadt. Und was es, finde ich, auch sehr schön zeigt, ist, dass solche datenjournalistischen Geschichten auch im Lokalen ganz gut funktionieren können. Und dass man dadurch auch einfach spannende Storys finden kann. Ich habe mir nämlich zum Beispiel mal angeguckt, okay, es kommen jetzt zum Beispiel 100 Leute aus irgendeinem kleinen Dorf in Marokko. 100 Leute bei einer sehr großen Population in Düsseldorf mag nicht viel scheinen. Wenn das Dorf aber winzig klein ist, kann das was aussagen. Das heißt, ich habe mal geschaut, wie verhält sich das überhaupt zur Einwohner- schaft von diesen Orten und wir haben festgestellt, gerade zum Beispiel bei Marokko, dass es ein paar Dörfer gibt, wo einfach ungewöhnlich viele Leute von nach Düsseldorf ziehen und dann ist eben eine Reporterin von der Zeitung losgegangen und hat sich die marokkanische Community in Düsseldorf näher angeguckt. Das wäre was, was wir sonst nicht gemacht hätten.
Aber ist das, habt ihr das nur aufgearbeitet oder war das dann irgendwie auch schön auf einer Karte zu gucken zum Rumscrollen oder?
Es war schön auf einer Karte zum Rumscrollen. Das mögen wir natürlich auch immer, wenn es hinterher immer schön klickibunt ist. Genau, das heißt, du konntest dann auf einer Karte sehen. Da waren dann irgendwie so farbige Kreise drauf. Je größer der Kreis, desto mehr Leute kommen aus diesem Ort. Es war halt eine Weltkarte und man kann sich jeden Ort der Welt angucken. Man kann auch Orte eingeben und da so ein bisschen selber erforschen. Und dazu gab es natürlich einen Text, der ein bisschen Hintergrundinformationen noch dazu gibt. Und noch, ja.
Und war das für dich so cool, weil diese Daten an der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich sind oder eher, weil man in den Daten wühlen konnte und dann Dinge rausfinden konnte?
So ein bisschen was von beidem. Also ich meine, dass die Daten öffentlich zugänglich sind, ist ja die Voraussetzung dafür, dass man da drin rumscrollen kann und dass man da Dinge rausfinden kann, nicht wahr?
Naja, das ist nur die Voraussetzung dafür, dass alle da drin rum jetzt auch einfach aufarbeiten können für euch.
Aber nun, wir sind ja ein journalistisches Medium. Das heißt, wir wollen es natürlich auch für alle, für ein großes Publikum zugänglich machen. Und ich meine, auch für Journalisten ist es natürlich sehr viel schöner, wenn die Daten schon offen für uns da sind, weil wir haben leider auch wirklich nicht ewig einfach immer Zeit. Und es ist manchmal schwer, an Daten zu kommen, wenn sie nicht schon offen bereitstehen. Das dauert dann lange. Das kann manchmal unmöglich sein. Und das kann Geschichten verhindern, die es wert sind, erzählt zu werden.
Darf ich auch noch drüber sprechen über die Präsentation?
Ja, die Projekte sind natürlich alle ganz toll. Und Zuckerguss und so. Eigentlich wollte ich über Codeflow erzählen, aber ich habe gerade nachgekuckt. Ich glaube, ich habe vergessen, die Server zu bezahlen. Das ist nicht mehr online.
Upsi, Schwierigkeiten als Datenjournalismus. Man muss den Server regelmäßig bezahlen.
Ja, das gebe ich an jemand weiter. Ich kann jetzt eigentlich nur alte Kamellen raushauen. Zumindest, was vielleicht mit Open Data was zu tun hat. Das war diese Open Plan B Geschichte damals. Wir hatten 2012 für die Süddeutsche den Zugmonitor gebastelt. Da konnte man die Züge, den Fernverkehr der Deutschen Bahn live sehen. Die Züge haben sich so schön rot eingefärbt, wenn sie verspätet sind. Das war so ein bisschen wie eine Art Modelleisenbahn in Deutschland. Man konnte dann sehen, Hannover wird immer roter. Dann gab es einen Pulk von Zügen, die dann halt losfahren. Für das Projekt, wir fanden das völlig absurd. Es gibt keinerlei öffentlichen Listen, wo die Bahnhöfe der Deutschen Bahn sind in Deutschland. Gibt es nicht. Ich hätte jetzt irgendwie gedacht, dass sie das jetzt geheim halten, wo der Bahnhof in Hannover ist. Wir durften diese Daten einfach nicht nutzen. Daraufhin habe ich geguckt, ob es irgendwie einen Hack gibt. Ich habe gefunden, dass auf den alten Fahrplan-CDs, da kann man ja auch so Zugauskunft machen und so weiter, gab es unter anderem eine Datei, die hieß Plan K-Geo. Da war da ein bisschen verschüsselt drin die Liste von Bahnhöfen und mit den Geokoinaten, die sind 300.000 Stück. Da konnte man ein bisschen rausscrapen. Dann hatte ich zu einem kleinen Hacking-Projekt auf Twitter aufgerufen, lass uns mal diese komplette Datenbank auseinandernehmen und den kompletten Fahrplan der Deutschen Bahn freilegen. Parallel habe ich dann einfach mal eine E-Mail geschrieben an rüdiger.ruberdeutschebahn.com, dass ich ihn gerne bei seiner Transparenzinitiative unterstützen möchte. Daraufhin habe ich dann einen Vorstellenden nach Frankfurt eingeladen, bin ich mit meinem Kollegen dahin gefahren. Wir haben ihm das im Prinzip erzählt, dass es eigentlich nicht mehr damals ins Jahr 2012 passt, dass die Deutsche Bahn ihre Fahrpläne nicht offenlegt, dass da irgendwelche Copywides drauf sind, dass man die nicht nutzen darf, dass man nicht eigene Apps bauen darf, was weiß ich, für barrierefreie Zugverbindungen und so weiter. Und genau, da haben wir dann so ein bisschen die Daten freigehackt, veröffentlicht, haben dann einfach mal ganz frech eine Open Data Lizenz draufgeklebt und daraufhin hat dann die Deutsche Bahn den ersten offenen Brief ihrer Geschichte geschrieben an Sergietta Kreil. Fanden wir jetzt nicht so eine tolle Aktion. Machen sie nicht normal, sonst gibt es juristische Konsequenzen. Zumindestens haben sie jetzt ein Open Data Portal. Die Fahrplandaten sind tatsächlich bis heute nicht offen. Also es gibt eine API, aber ich will jetzt, weiss ich nicht, du sagst einfach stopp, wenn ich zu viel rede. Okay, da kann man im Prinzip nachgucken.
Du könntest aber kurz erklären, was eine API ist.
Okay, ist eine kleine Programmierschnittstelle und ich kann selber ein Computerprogramm schreiben, das dann diese Schnittstelle abfragt. Beispielsweise sowas wie, ich möchte gerne von Berlin nach Stuttgart, wie komme ich denn da am besten hin? Und dann antwortet mir diese API da drauf.
Also die Bahn sozusagen stellt eine Art Standard zur Verfügung, wo man sagen kann, wenn man es auf eine gewisse Art und Weise programmiert, dann kann man auf diese Daten zugreifen.
Genau. Und so könnte ich mir meine eigene, was weiß ich, Zugauskunfts-App selber schreiben. Leider gibt es diese Art von API bis heute nicht von der deutschen Bahn. Das heißt, die einzige Möglichkeit daraus zu kriegen, von wo bis wo irgendwie mein Zug fährt, ist dann über die Bahn-Webseite oder die Bahn-Apps.
Bist du eigentlich jetzt auch einem Projekt, einer Institution, einem Medium zugeordnet oder bist du so freischaffender Datenwissenschaftler?
Ich bin gerade bei einem Unternehmen namens Infographics Group. Was wir da genau machen, weiß ich auch noch nicht so richtig.
Ist das so der Zustand von Datenschulnalismus 2018? Was wir da so genau machen, wissen wir auch nicht so richtig?
Momentan haben wir das Spielzeug HTC Vive und dann machen wir mal ein bisschen AR und dann ein bisschen VR und noch einen großen 4K-Touchscreen und spielen so ein bisschen rum. Gucken wir mal. Also irgendwas mit Daten wird es sein.
Okay, irgendwas mit Daten. Finde ich ganz spannend und würde genau jetzt an der Stelle auch weitermachen wollen, was wir dir gerade anklangen, nämlich dass es da schwierig war, an die Daten überhaupt ranzukommen. An euch drei fing jetzt die Frage und so wird die Sendung auch laufen. Wir gehen jetzt sozusagen einmal so einen Datenjournalisten oder Datenpräsentationsprojekt durch. Was ist denn am Anfang eigentlich? Ist am Anfang eine Datenquelle, wo man denkt, okay, die gucken wir uns jetzt an und gucken, was da ist? Oder ist es eigentlich, würde ich gerne mal wissen, dass und dann muss man da an die Daten rankommen? Wie gehen so eine Projekte oft los, Kira?
Also ich finde, das ist immer so ein bisschen die Henne- oder Eifrage. Die kommt auch ganz häufig so, was war zuerst da, die Daten oder die Geschichte? Ich glaube, also gerade ich erzähle das jetzt aus datenjournalistischer Perspektive. Die anderen Menschen, die was mit Daten machen, können mich dann gerne korrigieren für jeweiliges Feld. Es ist schon häufig so, dass man irgendwie mit einer These rangeht. Ich meine, wir sind Journalisten, wir wollen Geschichten erzählen. Das heißt, wir gehen häufig irgendwie mit einer These ran. Hier könnte irgendwie ein interessantes Thema sein. Wo könnte es Daten dazu geben? Was könnte es für Daten dazu geben? Wie kann man diese Geschichte aus Datenperspektive erzählen und gehen dann los und gucken, wo sind die Daten dafür? Es kann natürlich auch passieren, dass man irgendwie generell gerade stöbert, eigentlich nach was ganz Anderem sucht und auf einmal im Datenportal seines Vertrauens über ein Thema stolpert. Was total spannend ist. Es kann also auch sein, dass die Daten irgendwie am Anfang stehen und sich daraus eine Geschichte ergibt. Aber zumindest in meiner Erfahrung ist das häufig schon irgendwie so ein Thesen geleiteter Prozess.
Beim Aktivisten ist es glaube ich eher ein Gefühl am Anfang. Und ich glaube, das ist entweder Empörung oder Verzweiflung oder irgendwas dazwischen. Meistens bei mir geht es meistens los mit ganz normaler Nachrichtenlektüre. Und ich denke mir, ja, wir reden jetzt hier über, weiß ich nicht, Dieselgate oder sowas. Und wie kann es denn sein, dass wir hier über Daten reden und offensichtlich wahnsinnig viele Daten im Feld, wo ich mich bewege, vom Staat vor allem, rumliegen und wir die nicht sehen und wir die nicht selbst analysieren können und wir nicht selbst da rankommen. Und aus dieser Empörung, wenn man sie denn konstruktiv nutzt, kommt hoffentlich heraus, dass man entweder nicht nachfragt beim Staat. Wollt ihr das nicht rausgeben, das ist doch super für alle. Oder dass man versucht, auf ein bisschen aggressiveren Wegen an solche Daten ranzukommen.
Du machst also what the fuck getriebenen Datenaktivismus.
Vielleicht wird das der neue Slogan von der Open Knowledge Foundation.
Eigentlich ganz ähnlich wie bei Kira. Man kommt mit einer Geschichte, sucht nach den Daten, stellt dann fest, das geht aber gar nicht. Und dann sieht man, dass man aus den Daten was ganz anderes machen kann, dass es Fehler getrieben ist, vor sich hin zu basteln.
Jetzt, Kangerstuhl Arne hat es irgendwie gesagt, es gibt manchmal Schnittstellen, auf die man zugreifen kann, dann gibt es Datenportale, also ohne dass jetzt genauso, das stelle ich mir vor, das beschreibt ein wie auch immer gearteter Zugang zu Daten, die man aber schon fast zu verwenden kann. Jetzt, Arne, hast du davon erzählt, es gibt auch den Fall, dass man halt irgendwie Kopien von Faxen, die ausgedruckt und nochmal und so weiter und so fort ist. Aber sind das sozusagen die drei Möglichkeiten, an Daten zu kommen? Oder gibt es da noch so Zwischenstufen, wo man denkt, ich habe keine Ahnung, da steht was auf einer Webseite, aber das ist irgendwie nicht so praktisch zugreifbar. Da muss man noch irgendwas extra programmieren oder so. Oder generiert ihr auch selber Daten? Vielleicht müssen wir mal irgendwas messen, aufzeichnen, wie auch immer. Oder ist das Angebot an den Daten, die man entweder umbauen muss oder die man aus einer Schnittstelle oder in einem Portal ziehen kann, so groß, dass ihr damit erst mal beschäftigt seid?
Also ein ganz grundsätzliches Problem bei Open Data ist, es gibt keinen Rechtsanspruch auf Open Data. Das heißt, ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe das Recht, diesen Datensatz zu bekommen. Was es gibt, ist das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Ich habe Recht, Auskunft zu bekommen. Ich habe Recht, Akten einzusehen. Ich habe aber nicht das Recht, eine CSV oder eine Excel-Datei zu bekommen. Das heißt, ich habe vielleicht das Recht darauf, eine wieder eingescannte, noch mal ausgedruckte Liste zu bekommen. Und es gibt Ministerien, die machen das auch extra so, damit man ja nicht weiter mitarbeiten kann. Verkehrsministerium. Aber das heißt, man muss schauen, ob man entweder sehr kooperativ rangeht und versucht, die Verantwortlichen davon zu überzeugen, das zu veröffentlichen. Oder man kann schauen, ob man selbst Open Data macht. Und ich glaube, Michael hat das gerade mit der Bahngeschichte schon ein bisschen so angerissen. Ob man schauen kann, dass man selbst Daten scrapet aus verfügbaren Datenbanken, die aber nicht so aufbereitet sind, dass man die Daten direkt ziehen kann. Und dann vielleicht schaut, dass man selbst diese Daten so veröffentlicht.
Aber das ist ja alles sozusagen, es gibt die Daten schon. Sie sind nur mehr oder weniger zugänglich. Und wenn sie halt weniger zugänglich sind, dann muss man halt noch ein bisschen bohren. Es ist aber nicht so, dass ihr eure eigenen Daten erstellt. Oder zumindest irgendwie so ganz kleine atomare Daten so miteinander kombiniert, dass eigentlich eine neue Datenlage entsteht.
Das gibt es schon auch. Und da gibt es ein Premiumbeispiel für Luftdaten.info, die von Stuttgart ausgehen, inzwischen ein sehr, sehr großes Netz von Feinstaubsensoren in Deutschland installiert haben. Das ist ein Netzwerk von Ehrenamtlichen, die kleine Bausätze verteilen, 30 Euro das Stück. Da kann man sich selbst an den Balkon hängen und kann dann selbst anfangen, Feinstaub zu messen. Und das ist ein Projekt, das letztlich Open Data produziert. Also wir haben ein paar hundert dieser Feinstaubsensoren in Deutschland rumhängen. Die machen alle Daten, die alle frei zugänglich sind und die ein ziemlich interessantes Gegengewicht schaffen zu den staatlichen, deutlich weniger Feinstaubsensoren, die dann zum Beispiel in Stuttgart an zwei, drei Stellen rumhängen. Aber dieses Netzwerk kann dann sehr gut zeigen, wie jetzt die aktuelle Feinstaubbelastung in ganz Deutschland ist.
Ich kann noch ergänzen, es gibt noch Flightradar 24 und Marine Traffic. Das sind beide Seiten, die nach einem ganz ähnlichen System funktionieren. Plus, dass sie dann die 3D-Koordinaten der Flugzeuge mit Modellnummern, Flugnummern, keine Ahnung was sammeln. Beziehungsweise bei Marine Traffic die Position von Schiffen, die man dann zwar nicht auf dem Atlantik oder sowas empfangen kann, aber da kann man sich dann den Schifffarkehr durch den Suezkanal anschauen und so weiter. Und kann die Daten auch nutzen.
Da lesen die Quellen aus oder tragen Leute ein? Ich habe gerade Schiff so und so gesehen.
Konkret läuft es so, dass Schiffe und Flugzeuge so transponder Signale haben, damit auch zum Beispiel bei Nebel die andere Maschine oder das andere Schiff weiß, ach, da kommt mir jetzt was entgegen. Und weil das mit einer relativ großen Reichweite ausgestrahlt wird, kann man sich dann selber Hardware kaufen. Ich glaube, da wird auch so DVB-T-Sticks gehackt oder sowas. Und die können dann diese Transponder-Signale empfangen und schleifen das in eine zentrale Datenbank ein, wo es dann gebündelt wird im Prinzip. Gleitradar 24, kann man sich mal angucken, man kann so viele Flugzeuge unterwegs, so Planespotter-Bürgen, das glaube ich.
Jetzt Kira, das sind ja sozusagen, das sind ja alles Quellen, da hat man vielleicht so Nerdbedarf zu wissen, wo jedes Flugzeug gerade ist. Ich meine, manchmal ist das natürlich auch spannend, aber generell, dann gibt es hier sozusagen, das ist ja auch politisch motiviert vor allem, aber als Journalist will man ja etwas, wo hinterher eben eine Geschichte rausfällt.
Ja, absolut.
Wo gibt es denn Daten für Geschichten?
Prinzipiell letzten Endes überall. Also Datenjournalismus ist ja thematisch überhaupt nicht eingeschränkt, weil Daten gibt es letzten Endes zu allem. Es kommt halt ein bisschen drauf an, was gerade wichtig ist. Es ist letzten Endes nicht anders als im Rest des Journalismus. Man guckt halt, was ist wichtig, was ist eine Geschichte, und dann gibt es dazu Daten. Also wir arbeiten häufig tatsächlich mit offenen Daten, einfach auch, weil es ein bisschen die ressourcenschonendste Variante ist. Das heißt, wir sind auch angewiesen auf Open Data Aktivisten, die ein bisschen auch dafür sorgen, die mit Behörden auch zusammenarbeiten, um Daten zu befreien, weil das einfach nicht unser Job ist. Wir das aber auch auf jeden Fall brauchen. Dann aber auch, also in vielen Datenjournalismus-Teams gibt es auch Entwickler, gibt es Leute, die programmieren, die selber scrapen können, also automatisch Daten aus dem Netz erholen können. Und das ist in meiner Erfahrung auch eine sehr wertvolle Datenquelle, die ganz oft Sachen rausholen kann, die es so nicht direkt mit Download-Button gibt.
Dieses Scrapen, das würde ich gerne nochmal genauer fragen, was da der aktuelle Stand ist, also dieses Webseiten Scraping. Weil ich erinnere mich noch, es war zur Anfangszeit des Internets, wo RSS-Feeds noch, also sozusagen, wo die automatische Möglichkeit, sich Nachrichten zu abonnieren noch nicht so verbreitet waren, wo ich versucht habe, heute die Nachrichtenseite des ZDFs von Hand mit einem PHP-Skript auszulesen, was dazu geführt hat, dass mein Webposter meinen Server abgeschossen hat, weil der zu viel anfragt. Egal, aber ich dachte ja tatsächlich sozusagen, dass man sich Programme schreibt, die von Hand über eine Webseite drüber gehen und dann Dinge rauszuziehen, schon lange vorbei ist. Aber das ist auch noch ein wesentlicher Teil eurer Arbeit?
Ja, also zumindest für mich persönlich ist das extrem wichtig. Ich mache das sehr häufig. Auch häufig sind das einfach nur ganz kleine Programme, die zum Beispiel nichts anderes machen, als wenn es dann irgendwo ein Verzeichnis von Adressen von Ärzten in Berlin gibt, was es nirgendwo zum Download gibt. Dann schreibe ich mir halt ein Programm, was einfach das macht, was ich per Hand auch machen würde. Statt dass ich per Hand copy und pasten muss, macht der Computer das für mich und packt das mir direkt in ein handliches Tabellenformat. Viel schöner, immer noch nötig und sehr hilfreich.
Jetzt sind ja Webseiten mittlerweile riesengroß. Ist das einfacher geworden oder eher komplizierter, weil die so unfassbar viel Programmcode enthalten?
Das ist letztendlich nicht so mega das Problem, solange es auf die Website aufgebaut ist. Google-Suchergebnisse sind zum Beispiel ein bisschen schwieriger zu scrapen, weil die alles in irgendwelchen Skripten verstecken. Das heißt, es ist quasi gar nicht so richtig im Aufbau der Website von Anfang an drin, das was man auf dem Bildschirm sieht, sondern das wird erst generiert. Und was ich letztendlich mache, also was meine Programme machen, ist die Website von hinten angucken, sich den Aufbau anzugucken. Und da die Daten rauszuholen. Wenn die aber im Aufbau nicht von Anfang an drin stehen, sondern irgendwo versteckt herkommen, dann ist es schwieriger. Geht immer noch, aber macht es nervig.
Ist dann auch Absicht dahinter? Oder würdest du Absicht unterstellen bei so Webseiten, dass man sagt, die sind dann auch so programmiert, dass man da möglichst nicht automatisiert Sachen rausziehen kann?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also generell, man muss ja sagen, Scraping ist an sich ja nicht illegal. Trotzdem muss man sich natürlich ein bisschen Gedanken darüber machen, wer hat Copyright auf diese Daten. Zum Beispiel, es gibt halt Seiten, die auch ganz klar in ihren Nutzungsbedingungen sagen, du sollst nicht automatisch Daten abgreifen. Da muss man einfach rechtlich sehr vorsichtig sein. Das sind häufig, gerade wenn es irgendwelche großen Firmen sind, Seiten, die auch Abwehrmaßnahmen gegen Bots, gegen solche Programme eben haben. Da muss man aufpassen, da begibt man sich rechtlich manchmal auf dünnes Eis. Manchmal ist aber auch tatsächlich einfach nur so, dass die, weil es nun mal praktischer war, die Seite so zu bauen, so aufgebaut sind.
Okay, rechtliches dünnes Eis bei der Aufnahme von Daten, da können wir gleich nochmal genauer drüber reden. Wir machen jetzt erst den ersten kurzen Break mit, wie sich für ein Chaosradio gehört, NerdNews. Und die sind geschrieben dieses Mal von Mo und vorgetragen werden sie von Christina.
US-Bundesstaaten arbeiten an eigenen Gesetzen zur Netzneutralität. Die US-amerikanische Organisation Free Press hat eine Liste veröffentlicht, aus der hervorgeht, dass 27 US-Bundesstaaten an eigenen Gesetzen zur Sicherstellung der Netzneutralität arbeiten. In Dezember hatte die amerikanische Bundesbehörde FCC den Internet-Providern erlaubt, Datenverkehr im Internet unterschiedlich zu behandeln und damit de facto die Netzneutralität abgeschafft. Gleichzeitig wurden eigene Regelungen von Bundesstaaten und Kommunen verboten. Daher wird erwartet, dass es in den nächsten Monaten zu einer gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzung kommen wird. Für diesen Fall haben große amerikanische Internetkonzerne ihre Unterstützung im Kampf gegen die FCC-Entscheidung angekündigt. Open Schufa will Scoring transparent machen. Das Crowdfunding-Projekt Open Schufa versucht, herauszufinden, wie die Bonitätsauskunft bei Schufa ihr Scoring ermittelt. Der Score wird bei Ratenkäufen und anderen Vertragsabschlüssen zur Ermittlung der Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit von Zahlungen verwendet. Die Berechnungsmethode gilt als Betriebsgeheimnis und die Qualität der zugrunde liegenden Daten ist nicht bekannt. Open Schufa hofft, die Methoden und gegebenenfalls systemische Fehler der Scoringfirma offenlegen zu können und bittet dazu um Datenspenden von Schufa-Auskünften. Unterstützt wird Open Schufa von AlgorithmWatch, der Open Knowledge Foundation und Geldspenden. US-Magazin lässt Leser schürfen. Auf der Nachrichtenseite Salon kann die Werbung ausgeblendet werden, wenn man den Betreibern die ungenutzte Rechenleistung seines Rechners zur Verfügung stellt. Damit schifft die Webseite dann die Kryptowährung Monero und verbucht diese dann als Einnahmen. Alle 24 Stunden muss der Leser erneut der Nutzung zustimmen, sodass er jederzeit die Wahl zwischen Werbung und Mining hat. Sobald man die Seite verlässt und keine Inhalte mehr von Salon darstellt, wird auch das Mining beendet und die Leistungsabnahme unterbrochen. Vor allem Laptop- und Mobilgerätennutzer dürften jedoch weiter einen Adblocker bevorzugen.
So, im Chaosradio gibt es wie immer auch Creative Commons Musik. Die kommt dieses Mal von Data Fatale. Ein Musiker oder Musikerin, weiß gar nicht so genau, auf Bandcamp hat bis jetzt nur drei Songs veröffentlicht. Die hören wir heute alle hier im Chaosradio 243 über Open Data, Wissenschaft, Journalismus und Aktivismus. Herzlich willkommen zurück. So, wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde darüber gesprochen, dass man sich Daten irgendwoher besorgen muss. Das macht man über Portale oder Schnittstellen oder man zieht sie sich selber aus dem Netz oder hängt sogar Messstationen irgendwo auf. Und dann ganz zum Schluss kam so ganz nebenbei der Satz, ja, da könnte ja auch Copyright und juristische Konsequenzen möglicherweise, müsste man sich mal Gedanken machen. Entschuldigung, das würde ich jetzt tatsächlich gerne genau wissen. Also, weil der Punkt an diesem ganzen Ding, an dem wir heute reden, ist ja, ich nehme Daten irgendwoher und dann werfe ich da Datenmagie drauf und dann passen da irgendwie tolle Dinge mit. Wo kann denn auf Daten eine juristische Schwelle liegen, sag ich mal so?
Also, naja, Daten sind ja letzten Endes einfach nur eine Art von Information. Und auf Informationen können natürlich Leute Rechte haben. Also ich darf ja zum Beispiel auch nicht jedes Bild, was ich im Internet finde, einfach irgendwie weiter verbreiten oder im krassesten Fall noch irgendwie weiter verkaufen. Nur weil ich es sehen kann und es mir runterladen kann, heißt es ja nicht, dass ich es auch darf.
Na aber bei Bild gibt es ja Persönlichkeitsrechte, Schöpfungshöhe, Kunstwerk, Urheberrecht.
Und genau das gilt für Datensätze auch. Es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass wenn eine Datenbank mit viel Mühe irgendwie zum Beispiel von einer privaten Firma vielleicht sogar zusammengestellt wurde, dass die zwar einsehbar ist, dass man sich vielleicht Auszüge davon angucken kann, dass man sie aber trotzdem nicht kommerziell weiterverbreiten kann. Auf Daten kann genauso Copyright liegen, das kann genauso eine Schöpfungshöhe haben, Urheberrechte drauf haben, wie andere Arten von Informationen auch.
Und das sozusagen eine journalistische Bearbeitung von Daten ist schon eine kommerzielle Weitergabe oder?
Also viele journalistische Medien sind ja privatwirtschaftlich organisiert, das heißt, es sind tatsächlich einfach Unternehmen, die machen ja tatsächlich sogar Gewinn dann mit den Geschichten, die sie verkaufen und wenn die Geschichten auf den Daten basieren, dann machen sie ja Gewinn mit den Daten auf jeden Fall.
Ist euch schon mal was gescheitert, weil die Daten waren zwar da, aber das war dann zu teuer? Oder beziehungsweise ihr wolltet nicht das Recht so hin brechen, dass es ging?
Ja, da kann ich ein gutes Beispiel bringen. Beim Oder-Hochwasser hatte das Deutsche Luft- und Raumfahrtzentrum Luftbildaufnahmen zur Verfügung gestellt, die zeigen, wo gerade Überschwemmungsgebiete sind und wollten da enorm viel Kohle für haben, um die nutzen zu dürfen. Fand ich damals eine Frechheit. Bin aber nicht weiter der Geschichte nachgegangen. Witzigerweise habe ich auf der Webseite gefunden, dass man die Originaldaten auch raushacken konnte, aber wir wollten uns jetzt nicht darauf einlassen. Aber eigentlich müsste man das thematisieren, dass gerade bei Katastrophenschutz oder so was diese Daten einfach nicht geheim oder geschützt sein dürfen.
Wir haben grundsätzlich sehr oft das Problem, dass Daten etwas kosten. Also gerade die Statistischen Bundesämter, deren Aufgabe ist, einfach Daten zu sammeln zu zentralen Themen, bieten viele dieser Daten nur zum Verkauf an. Das heißt, man muss erst mal investieren, um dann eine Liste von Schulen zu bekommen oder so. Das ist teilweise echt grotesk, weil ja diese Statistischen Ämter sowieso schon steuerfinanziert sind, die aber dann ein Geschäftsmodell haben und ihre Daten verkaufen. Und das sind dann meistens auch noch mal Daten, die man dann vielleicht irgendwie nutzen kann, aber wiederum nicht weiterverwenden. Das heißt, dann noch mal irgendwelche Urheberrechte drauf, die dann eine Weiternutzung verhindern. Zum Beispiel, dass man sie selbst zum Download anbietet. Das heißt, dass man sie anreichert mit anderen Daten und dann sagt, jetzt ladet euch die alle runter. Wir haben die jetzt aus drei Bundesländern gekauft zusammen.
Das heißt, ihr könntet dann Erkenntnisse daraus präsentieren. Aber ihr müsstet dann sagen, wir wissen das, weil die Daten bei uns ja auch liegen. Aber wir können es euch leider nicht sozusagen mit Quellen geben.
Genau, so ungefähr ist es. Hier, wenn ihr das noch mal genauer wissen wollt, dann investiert ihr auch noch mal 100 Euro.
Aber ich meine, ich weiß, das ist für manche Leute viel Geld. Aber man kann auch sagen, okay, 100 Euro, naja, das kriegt man vielleicht noch gerade, wenn man irgendwie eine gut gelittene, aktivistische Organisation ist, kriegt man das auch irgendwie hin. Ist das eher eine Hürde oder ist das ein ernsthaftes Problem mit dem Geld?
Das ist ein ernsthaftes Problem, weil die Idee hinter Open Data für uns ist, diese Daten so vielen Menschen wie möglich zugänglich zu machen. Das heißt nicht, dass wir nur irgendwie damit arbeiten wollen, ein bisschen rumlerden wollen, sondern dass Betroffene, dass Leute, die eben nicht diese Mittel haben, damit dann was anfangen können. Dass Apps daraus entstehen können, dass Aktivisten für ihre Ideale einstehen können und was damit machen können. Und wenn es solche Hürden gibt, dann wird das verhindert.
Wir reden da heute nicht drüber, weil wir tatsächlich darüber reden wollen, was mit den Daten ist, aber das ist sozusagen auch Teil eures Aktivismus. Dass ihr dafür kämpft und eintretet, dass genau das nicht mehr der Fall ist.
Genau und das ist dann glaube ich unsere Aufgabe, eventuell dann auch mal juristisch nicht so klare Fälle vor Gericht zu bringen, um dann mal zu klären, wie ist das denn mit diesem Datenbank-Schutzrecht? Und das würden dann sicher nicht einzelne Journalisten machen, das würden dann sicher nicht einzelne Leute machen und dafür sind wir da.
Verstehe, verstehe. Michael, du hast ja auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress auch einen Vortrag über Socialbots gehalten und jetzt ist ja tatsächlich so soziale Netzwerke an sich sind ja auch eine, also A ein Thema, was uns jetzt die ganze Zeit beschäftigt und B könnte ich mir vorstellen auch eine reichhaltige Datenquelle. Was mich da bei Frage ist, wo kriegst du die Daten her? Diese Netzwerke bieten ja immer auch Schnittstellen an, wo man also vor allen Dingen für die werbetreibenden Statistikdaten rausziehen kann, aber womit arbeitest du da?
Also es ist genau auch diese eine Schnittstelle. Es gibt da die offizielle Twitter Developer API, eine Programmierschnittstelle, mit der ich dann beispielsweise Twitter durchsuchen kann, mir zu bestimmten Accounts Informationen rausholen kann und so weiter. Kann man sich hinsetzen, Programm schreiben, dass die Daten automatisch rauszieht und die werden zum Beispiel sehr intensiv genutzt, um im Falle von Brexit, Ukraine-Votum, US-Wahlen, aber auch in Deutschland zu beobachten, was auf Twitter abgeht, um da irgendwie Socialbots zu suchen, Trolle zu beobachten und so weiter. Und es gibt ganz viele wissenschaftliche Publikationen, die damit arbeiten und da kann ich jetzt auch gleich mal wieder einen Bogen spannen zurück zur Open Data, denn es ist interessanterweise nicht Open Data, denn die Daten, die ich dort rausziehe, sind unter dieser Twitter Developer Guideline sozusagen verschlossen in der Art, so eine Art RGB, die dafür sorgt, dass wenn es die Datenmenge eine bestimmte Größe erreicht, ich glaube irgendwas wie 10.000 Tweets oder so was, darf ich sie nicht mehr veröffentlichen. Und das führt zu einem Problem, dass mir jetzt in den letzten Monaten immer wieder aufgefallen ist, die Wissenschaftler, die mit diesen Daten arbeiten und dann ihre Theorien zu Social Bots und so weiter in Form von wissenschaftlichen Papers veröffentlichen, dürfen ihre Daten dazu nicht veröffentlichen. Das heißt, ich kann auch gar nicht diese Paper überprüfen. Das ist ein ganz schwerer Verstoß in der Wissenschaft, dass ich diese Paper nicht überprüfen kann.
Aber wäre nicht ein Umweg, dass man sagt, also die ziehen die Daten heraus. Das tun sie ja. Man könnte sagen, das ist eine Suchanfrage an den Twitter-Datensatz. Könnte man nicht, wenn man nicht die Daten nicht veröffentlichen kann, die exakte Suchanfrage veröffentlichen oder quasi den Programmiercode, für den der zugreift?
Das kann man tun, aber man kann halt nicht davon ausgehen, dass die Daten sich zwischendurch verändert haben. Zum Beispiel, weil Tweets gelöscht werden, weil zum Beispiel irgendwelchen rechten Trolle aus Twitter verbannt werden, deswegen alle Tweets nicht mal erreichbar sind und so weiter. Das hat ja schon, das hat ja schon Effekt, gerade wenn ich Sachen nach einem Jahr oder sowas überprüfen möchte, habe ich gar nicht die Chance, in die Originaldaten anzukommen.
Vielen Dank, dass du mich genau da angebracht hast, wo ich jetzt als nächstes hinwollte, nämlich, ihr arbeitet ja mit Daten und wir kommen da noch drauf, was ihr dann alles draus bastelt, aber ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt ist ja, dass die Daten, die ihr habt, stimmen. Ist das ein Problem? Gibt es da eine Art und Weise, das nachzuprüfen? Wie wichtig ist denn deine Arbeit? Also, ich meine, an den Haaren herbeigezogenes Beispiel, aber es gibt jetzt also diese Feinstaubbelastungsstationen. Natürlich kann man davon ausgehen, wenn sich das hunderttausend Leute hinhängen und sich jetzt hunderttausend Datensätze haben, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall ist, dass das falsche Daten sind, aber woher weiß ich es und spielt das eine Rolle?
Kann ich zwei Beispiele dazu bringen, über die ich selber gestolpert bin. Das eine ist, es gibt einen Verband der Schönheitschirurgen, den internationalen, der Statistiken veröffentlicht hat, über wie viele Schönheitsoperationen, in welchem Land, zu welchem Thema stattgefunden haben. Da haben wir uns ein bisschen tiefer reingegraben, haben festgestellt, dass es tatsächlich unterschiedliche Kulturräume gibt. Also die einen mögen ihren Popo zu vergrößern, die anderen ihre Nase zu verkleinern und keine Ahnung was. Und umso tiefer wir in die Daten reingestoßen sind, haben wir festgestellt, irgendwie so richtig sauber sieht das Ganze nicht aus. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus, als ob da irgendwie noch ein bisschen nachgefeilt wurde. Und dann haben wir aber nachgeguckt und tatsächlich haben sie dann ihre ganzen Statistiken zurückgezogen und haben neue Daten veröffentlicht. Also manchmal machen sie halt Umfragen und versuchen das irgendwie hochzurechnen für ein Land. Und dann sind die Daten nicht mehr ganz so sauber. Ganz typisches Beispiel ist auch bei den Wahlen. Da muss man halt darauf achten, welche sozusagen Genauigkeit diese Hochschätzung haben. Also da gibt es jetzt vor kurzem die Aussage, AfD hat jetzt die SPD in den Wahlsonntagsfragen überholt, mit einem halben Prozentpunkt drunter steht, aber mit einer Genauigkeit 2, 5 Prozent. Kann man das nur angeben.
Also das Ergebnis stimmt nur so genau, dass es auch 2, 5 Prozent weniger oder mehr sein könnte?
Exakt, genau. Und dann ist es natürlich Käse. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel, und das muss man auch mal erwähnen, das sind die polizeilichen Kriminalitätsstatistiken. Abgekürzt PKS. Intern in unserem Team haben wir es nur noch Pisse, Kacke, Scheiße genannt. Wir sind ja nicht öffentlich.
Doch, das Internet hört zu.
Also das Prinzip, umso tiefer wir mit diesen Daten gearbeitet haben, umso mehr Merkwürdigkeiten uns aufgefallen sind, haben wir auch angefangen mit Polizisten drüber zu sprechen, wie diese PKS im Alltag angelegt wird. Um es mal ganz provokativ zu formulieren, das ist eigentlich eine Denoziationsdatenbank. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was ich, wenn ich meinen Nachbarn beschuldige, oder irgendwie sowas, das sind ja gar nicht Straftäter, sondern es sind nur Verdächtige, die dort erfasst werden. Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt daraus irgendwelche Schätzungen mache, wie zum Beispiel Ausländerkriminalität oder sowas, hat das eigentlich gar keine Aussage. Weil es könnte ja einfach einen Trend geben, dass die Leute jetzt doppelt so häufig in bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppen und verdächtigen oder nicht. Es hat eigentlich nicht wirklich eine Aussage über die Kriminalität. Da müsste man sich eigentlich dann die Justizstatistiken angucken, wie es tatsächlich verklagt wird oder schuldig gesprochen wird.
Auch noch mal aus journalistischer Perspektive zum Thema, wie stellt man sich das Daten überhaupt stimmen? Das ist natürlich ein total wichtiges Problem. Und das ist im Journalismus was, was wir einfach mit einer gewissen journalistischen Sorgfaltpflicht angehen müssen, die wir immer brauchen. Wir müssen zum Beispiel ja auch überprüfen, stimmt die Information, die unser Interviewpartner uns gegeben hat, stimmen die Informationen, über die wir so berichten. Und das gilt auf jeden Fall auch für Daten. Da helfen auch normale journalistische Sorgfaltskriterien, normale Quellenkritik einfach. Es ist aber besonders wichtig, meiner Meinung nach, im Datenjournalismus, weil Zahlen, Daten, Fakten erwecken sehr schnell den Eindruck von Objektivität. Da steht eine Zahl, dann muss es ja wohl stimmen.
Das wollte ich gerade noch mal fragen. Beim Interviewpartner kann man sich immer darauf zurückziehen, dass man sagt, also nicht wir sagen, sondern wir sagen, der Typ oder die Type hat gesagt Folgendes. Und bei Daten ist ja aber exakt das der Fall. Dann wird halt eine schöne Grafik veröffentlicht und dann ist das ja so.
Genau, und genau das muss man eben in der Kommunikation verhindern. Genau dieser Macht muss man sich da einfach auch bewusst sein. Ein Schritt ist zum Beispiel wirklich auch da, eine Quellentransparenz durchzusetzen. Auch gerne einfach mehr Quellentransparenz, als im Journalismus häufig praktiziert wird. Also da wirklich auch klar zu sein, woher kommen die Daten, möglichst einen Link zum Original-Datensatz, möglichst vielleicht einen lustigen Infobutton reinmachen, der erklärt, was bedeuten die Daten eigentlich wirklich. Und sehr sorgfältig über Formulierungen und Darstellungsmethoden nachdenken. Also ich überlege, was bewirkt das gerade? Was sagt das gerade aus? Sagt es das aus, was ich vermitteln möchte? Und das ist nicht immer einfach, weil, also ich meine, ich bin Datenjournalistin, ich bin keine Statistikerin. Ich kann für Journalistenverhältnisse sehr viel Statistik und für Statistikerverhältnisse sehr wenig Statistik. Aber ich weiß gerade so genug, um zu wissen, wann ich mir Unterstützung holen muss. Und das halte ich da auch für unglaublich wichtig, dass man im Zweifelsfall nochmal nachfragt bei jemandem, der sich auskennt, bei jemandem, der wirklich die Statistik studiert hat oder das Fach studiert hat und mir sagen kann, habe ich das jetzt gerade richtig interpretiert?
Ich war ja gerade noch bei den Daten, ob die überhaupt stimmen, aber wo du gerade dabei bist, noch die Frage ist, ist das bei Redaktionen ein Problem, wenn man sagt, also wir können das machen, aber bitte schreibt unten dran, dass und das sind die Quellen. Also größere Quellentransparenz, das man normalerweise hat.
Genau, also das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig. Trotzdem können wir natürlich die Geschichte nicht machen, wenn die Daten nicht stimmen.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist witzig. Du weintest ja gerade, man muss eine größere Quellentransparenz an den Tag legen, als man es normalerweise tut. Das heißt auch dem Ergebnis mitliefern. Ja, das stelle ich mir vor, wenn man Redaktionsalltag kennt und dann sozusagen nicht, dann redet man ja nicht nur im Datenjournalisten-Team, sondern irgendwann ja auch mit dem normalen Chef vom Dienst und so, der dann entscheiden muss, okay, wie viel kommt dahin? Ist da auch bei den Nicht-Auskennern, sage ich mal, dann das Verständnis da, dass es da mehr Bedarf oder ist das eher so, ah, das sieht aber nicht so gut aus, wenn wir unsere eigene Arbeit anzweifeln, können wir das vielleicht irgendwie kleiner machen und Schriftgröße 4 und so?
Ja, also das passiert, das passiert einfach und das ist auch was, was einfach durch den Arbeitsalltag so ein bisschen bedingt ist. Also ganz krass ist es zum Beispiel bei Medien, die einfach eine Platz- oder eine Zeitbeschränkung haben. Im Radio kann ich nicht immer ganz lange erklären, was jetzt gerade meine Quelle ist, wenn wir nicht diese wunderbaren zwei Stunden gerade haben. Im Print habe ich vielleicht die drei Zeilen nicht, die genau das erklären. Da muss man manchmal ein bisschen dafür kämpfen, dass diese Daten, dass diese Angaben wichtig sind und manchmal klappt es und manchmal klappt es dann leider auch nicht.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ein wunderbares Beispiel dafür, warum Open Data so wichtig ist, um eben so eine Überprüfbarkeit zu schaffen. Also die Fehler in den Daten, die sind ja sowieso da. Also die Fehler in der Kriminalitätsstatistik, die sind da und die waren immer da. Wenn man die offen zur Verfügung stellt, diese Daten, dann ist es wahrscheinlicher, dass diese Fehler auffallen. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Grund dafür, warum viele staatliche Stellen sich gerade dagegen wehren, ihre Daten wirklich zu öffnen, weil die Schiss haben, dass rauskommt, dass da Fehler drin sind. Und das will natürlich niemand gern sehen.
Das ist eine der häufigsten Ursachen, die ich gehört habe dazu, von Unternehmen und Verwaltung.
Dass sie nicht wollen, dass man so genau drauf guckt. Ist das eigentlich, ist das eine spannende Frage, ist das, weil die irgendwie Dreck am Stecken haben, was verbergen wollen oder ist das eher so diese Angst, okay, da kann man uns jetzt ganz genau nachgucken, wer weiß, vielleicht haben wir ja irgendwann mal einen Fehler.
Ja, also in meiner Erfahrung ist das selten Böserwille. Also in meiner Erfahrung sind generell sehr wenige Dinge Böserwille. Aber ist ja die Frage ein bisschen, was ist die Intention und was ist der Effekt? Manchmal kommt das gleiche raus, egal ob man böswillig handelt oder nicht. Aber häufig, also gerade in Deutschland ist mir halt aufgefallen, dass einfach viele Behörden, also kannst du gleich auch noch mal auf jeden Fall mehr zu sagen, Arne, erstens nicht wissen, dass es so was wie Informationsfreiheit gibt und dann dem braten auch nicht so ganz trauen, so wie wir müssen das jetzt machen, wie oder jetzt müssen wir unsere Datenleuten geben, die das vielleicht dann irgendwie falsch darstellen und irgendwie wissen wir auch nicht so genau, was wir hier haben. Da ist häufig so ein, ja, so ein Fußesunmosein tatsächlich da.
Okay, könnt ihr da Aufklärungsarbeit leisten, Arne? Oder Frucht, also wollt ihr ja eh, aber fruchtet die auch?
Ja, wir haben eine ganze Palette von Best Practices. Und am Anfang hatte ich ja Kleine Anfragen.de erwähnt, die Hauptnutzergruppe von Kleine Anfragen.de ist die Verwaltung selbst. Weil die über Kleine Anfragen, weil die über Kleine Anfragen besser an ihre eigenen Dokumente kommen als über ihre eigenen blöden Systeme. Und das zeigt natürlich wunderbar, was die Kraft dieser ganzen Projekte ist, wenn die Verwaltung darüber selbst besser an die eigenen Daten kommt.
Das erinnert mich an eine Geschichte, die ich mal beim Radiosender gearbeitet habe, wo natürlich häufig auch mal so Hörer fragen, was lief denn eigentlich da dann und da dieser Song irgendwie um die und die Uhrzeit? Und dann, wenn halt keiner aus der Musikredaktion da war, der in dieses total arcane MS-DOS-basierte Musikplanungssystem reingucken konnte, gab es halt im Netz, da hat jemand einfach den, es gibt ja auf den Radiosender-Webseiten gibt es ja mal dieses, der Titel wird angezeigt und er hat das einfach sozusagen mitgescralt oder mitgetrackt. Da konnte man da sehr, sehr sozusagen sehr komfortabel gucken, wie es ist. Das ist ja unfassbar. Aber sozusagen ist es noch nicht soweit, dass die dann denken so, hey, eigentlich ist es ganz geil, wir machen das vielleicht besser selber?
Na, wir machen es ja ganz gut, ne?
Ja, naja, aber da hast du ja gesagt, wir schalten.
Ne, also eine interessante Frage wäre, was passiert, wenn wir kleine Anfragen abschalten? Was machen die dann?
Kann sie in den Streik gehen. Not bad. Michael, du hast gerade das Mikrofon so sprichbereit.
Ja, weil genau die gleiche Geschichte, und ich will jetzt nicht damit nerven, aber auch bei der Bahn tatsächlich aufgetreten ist, die haben dort 17 interne Datenportale. Das ist mal so Auftragssoftware, das könnt ihr euch ungefähr vorstellen, wie viel Spaß die macht, gar nicht. Und es gibt ein anderes Projekt, das heißt Open Railway Map, die nichts weiter macht, als Open Street Map-Daten auf einer Karte darzustellen, dabei aber sich speziell auf Eisenbahninfrastruktur, Gleise, Signale, Weichen und so weiter zu konzentrieren. Und die hätten natürlich auch gerne mehr Daten von der Deutschen Bahn. Ich hatte mich mit ihr unterhalten und da kam halt raus, dass aus dem IP-Adressraum der Deutschen Bahn die zweitgrößte Nutzergruppe ist. Also die Bahn nutzt dieses offene Datenportal am meisten. Und da konnten wir das Argument wieder zurückspielen, nennen und packt mal eure Infrastrukturdaten so raus, dass ihr auf der Railway Map das nutzen kann, damit ihr in eure eigenen Daten reinschauen könnt. Und das hat funktioniert.
Das hat funktioniert. Ich frage mich manchmal, ob das dann so ist, dass sozusagen der Zugriff auf den IP-Adressraum, das sind halt Leute, die müssen damit arbeiten. Die Entscheidung aber wird an anderer Stelle getroffen.
Also was ich immer auch ganz spannend finde, ist, so ein bisschen die andere Seite mitzubekommen. Also die Behördenseite einfach so ein bisschen. Auch wie, selbst wenn der Wille da ist, Daten zu befreien, wie schwer das häufig ist, das durchzusetzen, wie viele Bedenken da auch von interner Seite einfach erst mal zerstreut werden müssen. Also und wie viel das ausmachen kann, wenn sich jemand wirklich dafür einsetzt. Also es gibt, ich komme aus dem Rheinland, es gibt dann eine Stadt, die heißt Mörs. Es ist so ein kleiner Ort in der Nähe von Düsseldorf. So Düsseldorf, Duisburg, so die Ecke. Und da gibt es einen Menschen in der Stadtverwaltung, Klaus Arndt, der setzt sich seit Jahren für offene Daten ein. Und deswegen hat dieser kleine Ort Mörs eine extrem gute offene Datenstruktur. Die stellen viele, viele Datensätze auf einem offenen Datenportal, was auch sehr angenehm zu benutzen ist, tatsächlich online. Und der ist viel in Kommunikation mit der Open Knowledge Foundation zum Beispiel vor Ort, mit Journalisten und braucht auch immer und immer wieder Beispiele, dass Leute diese Daten auch wirklich benutzen, um überhaupt intern zu rechtfertigen Leuten, guck mal hier, das bringt was, wenn wir das offen stellen, da passiert was mit. Und das braucht er einfach, um das überhaupt durchzusetzen. Das ist wirklich ein jahrelanger Kampf, und der befreit jeden Datensatz von Hand quasi, indem er zu den Leuten hingeht.
Nicht schlecht, gut. Jetzt haben wir eine Stunde drüber geredet, wo man die Daten eigentlich herkriegt und was damit schon verbunden ist. Wir fangen gleich damit an, was man damit eigentlich genau machen kann. Also konkret haben wir es ja schon ab und zu gehört, aber ein bisschen abstrakt davor gibt es noch eine kleine Musik von DataFatale, die auch genau so heißt, DataFatale, und danach geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio 243 über Open Data. So, Halbzeit im Chaosradio 243, jetzt geht's weiter. Wir haben jetzt die Daten, trotz aller Probleme, trotz aller Schwierigkeiten haben wir es da. Jetzt machen wir was damit. Was machen wir denn damit? Arne bei Frag den Staat und keine anfragen.de stelle ich mir das Ergebnis, also ich habe immer das Gefühl bei euch, es ist das Schwierigste die Daten zu besorgen. Wenn man sie denn hat, dann sorgt man einfach nur noch dafür, dass sie halt in einer besonders guten, also gut lesbaren, möglichst maschinenlesbaren Form zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Dann ist es bei euch eigentlich erledigt.
Dann geben wir es Kira und Michael und die machen dann was damit. Das ist eine Möglichkeit. Wir geben es vielleicht an die OK Labs, also an Open Knowledge Labs, die es in ganz Deutschland gibt, damit die Visualisierung bauen damit zum Beispiel. Also irgendwie diese Datensätze erfahrbar machen. Idealerweise schauen, ja okay, wenn wir das jetzt in Berlin haben, wenn wir jetzt die Daten über die Wasserqualität des Leitungswassers in Berlin haben und jetzt diese Anwendungen haben, wo man das schnell checken kann für sich. Ja, wenn wir es in Berlin haben, dann wollen wir es in Köln aber auch. Und dann wollen wir es aber auch in Heilbronn und so weiter. Und dann kann man es da redeployen. Das ist dann so der nächste Weg, aber der ist dann nicht unbedingt man noch bei den Daten befreiern.
Ja, okay, also wenn man diese überstrapazierte Metapher von Daten als Öl benutzt, seid ihr quasi die Förderer und danach geht es in die Raffinerie.
Ich würde gerne diese Metapher anzünden.
Passt ja auch, ist ja Öl. Kira, was macht ihr jetzt mit den Daten?
Eine ganze Menge, Journalismus machen wir mit den Daten.
Ja, aber wie sieht das aus? Also ich meine, da hat man halt diesen Datenberg, der ist auch irgendwie zugänglich. Dann gibt es ja zwei Fragen. Die eine ist, wie ziehe ich daraus eine Erkenntnis? Also rühr ich die so lange um, bis da irgendwer rausfällt? Und wenn ja, was ist in dieser Metapher der Kochtopf und der Löffel? Und dann, wie präsentiert man es so, dass es auch Leute versteht, die keine Datenjournalisten sind?
Okay, also unsere Ziel ist ja immer eine Geschichte mit den Daten zu erzählen. Das heißt, im Idealfall haben wir jetzt einen wunderbaren Datensatz gefunden, der irgendwie, wo wir was Interessantes drin sehen, was irgendwie eine journalistische Geschichte werden kann. Dann müssen wir die Daten irgendwie erst mal sauber machen, weil im Zweifelsfall sind sie in irgendeinem PDF. Müssen wir erst mal in schöne Tabellenform bringen, sodass wir sie weiterverarbeiten können. Müssen sie dann vielleicht analysieren, mal gucken, was ist irgendwie der größte Wert, was ist der kleinste Wert, wo ist der jüngste Kiez in Berlin. Das kann sich natürlich währenddessen einfach nochmal verändern. Wir müssen ja auch, ich meine, die Geschichte kann ja nicht ohne die Daten geschehen. Wir gehen mit einer Idee ran, was da drin sein kann. Und in der Recherche, in der Datenanalyse kommen dann bestimmte Aspekte raus, die wir besonders interessant finden, wie zum Beispiel, ich hatte ja zum Anfang schon mal von diesem Projekt erzählt, woher die Düsseldorfer kommen. Und da ist mir nämlich zum Beispiel erst dann aufgefallen, dass diese kleinen Gemeinden in Marokko so spannend sind, nachdem ich die Daten schon längst hatte, schon längst in hübsche Form gebracht habe für mich selber, für die Analyse. Und dann mal geguckt habe, welcher Prozentsatz der Bevölkerung von diesem kleinen Ort ist denn jetzt nach Düsseldorf gezogen und habe festgestellt, oh, das ist irgendwie ein ziemlich großer Teil in drei verschiedenen Dörfern. Was machen die denn alle in Düsseldorf? Das ist eine Geschichte. Und dann ist die Frage, wie bereiten wir das auf? Weil letzten Endes ist es tatsächlich so, dass ich es vielleicht mag, auf Excel-Tabellen zu starren, aber unsere Leser, Hörerinnen und Hörern, außer mir, dann halt niemand, genau. Deswegen wollen wir das unserem Publikum natürlich auch nicht antun. Und das kann, also Datenschule, und das läuft häufig online. Einfach weil wir da viele lustige Möglichkeiten haben, daraus bunte Grafiken zu machen, eine hübsche Karte zu machen. Balken-Diagramme sind vielleicht nicht das schönste Beispiel, aber schöne bunte Grafiken, wo man auf einen Blick sehen kann, aha, hier, das ist die Geschichte. Dieser Balken ist viel länger als einer anderen. Oh, das ist spannend im Idealfall. Es kann aber auch heißen, ich mache daraus ein Radiostück. Also ich habe eine Hintergrundrecherche gemacht und die sagt mir jetzt, aha, dieser Teil von Düsseldorf wäre jetzt total spannend mal zu besuchen. Und dann geht der Reporter los und stellt sich dahin und sagt, hier, ich stehe jetzt an der so und so Straße, hier leben so und so viele Marokkaner, ungewöhnlich viele. Wir gehen in dieses Café, hier lebt die Familie sowieso und macht daraus eine klassische journalistische Reportage. So kann es auch passieren.
Jetzt gibt es ja aber, also durchs Netz geht es nicht. Was will man, eine interessante Datenrecherche? Also ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt so in semi-regelmäßigen Abständen, kommt meistens sind es so Zeitungsportale um die Ecke mit. Wir haben mal hier eine schöne Visualisierung für was auch immer. Was ich mich frage ist, was kann die klassischjournalistischen Inhalte machen, die über die klassischen Verbreitungswege gehen? Dann hängt es natürlich auch davon ab, wie hoch ist der Erkenntnis aus den Daten geworden? Wie gut ist die Geschichte auch journalistisch handwerklich gemacht? Bei diesen Daten, habt ihr da Einblicke, werden diese Visualisierungen wirklich genutzt? Oder ist das eher so, guck mal, das ist bunt, das kann man gut retweeten, aber eigentlich guckt sich ja jetzt keiner die Sachen genau an.
Also man muss ehrlich sagen, gegen Dschungelcamp kommt Datenjournalismus nicht an.
Wahrscheinlich auch als Chaosradio, auch wenn sie traurige Wahrheit ist von der Quoten her.
Genau, also dagegen kommen wir letzten Endes nicht an, aber das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht das Ziel so richtig. Und ansonsten muss man sagen, das wird tatsächlich durchaus genutzt, einfach weil es macht vielleicht dem Publikum auch tatsächlich Spaß, nicht irgendwie eine Wand an Text zu lesen, sondern irgendwie zwischendurch mal zu verschnaufen und sich was Buntes anzugucken. Was auch immer wirklich wirklich gut läuft, ist was, wo ich meine eigene Adresse eingeben kann. Da steht eine größere Geschichte hinter. Ich kann mir irgendwie die ganze Welt angucken, aber zu der ganzen Welt habe ich vielleicht nicht so einen Bezug wie zu der Straße, wo ich wohne, das kenne ich. Da sehe ich die lustigen Häuser und ich sehe dann, ah okay, hier kommen also auch 50 Leute her, die jetzt in Düsseldorf leben, abgefahren.
Also ich muss ja, ich habe neulich in so einer Ausstellung, wo es um Geheimdienste und Sicherheit ging, gesehen, hier in diesem, können sie ihr Passwort eingeben, wir checken, wir sichern das. Und es ist dasselbe und ich persönlich habe dasselbe Gefühl, auch immer wenn irgendwo steht, gib mal deine Adresse. Ich so, nice try, aber nein. Vielleicht dürft ihr wissen, wo meine Großmutter wohnt oder so, aber da haben Leute tatsächlich Interesse dran.
Ja, also ich möchte dir jetzt nichts unterstellen, aber vielleicht bist du auch ein bisschen paranoider als der Durchschnittsmensch. Das kann überhaupt gar nicht sein.
Was habt ihr aus mir gemacht?
Also ich verspreche auch, wir nutzen die Daten nicht um, sie an irgendwelche Werbefirmen weiter zu verkaufen. Ganz subtil sind wir noch nicht gesunken. Wir werden sehen. Ich hoffe, weder noch. Ich glaube, das wird nicht so passieren. Nein, natürlich nicht. Also Nutzerdaten zu speichern ist natürlich was, da muss man transparent mit sein und sonst was. Es kann natürlich auch was Schönes sein, dass man sagt, ich vergleiche mich jetzt mit den anderen Lesern. Zum Beispiel gibt es immer wieder Geschichten, zeichne selber mal die deutsche Teilung ein, zeichne selber mal die Berliner Mauer ein. Und wir stellen fest, du bist schlechter als 80% der anderen Leser. Du hast also keine Ahnung, du kommst aus dem Rheinland, Kira, bitte, ehrlich, geh. Da ist dann vielleicht was, wo es auch ganz nett ist, sich mit anderen Nutzer zu vergleichen. Aber ansonsten machen wir das natürlich nicht. Und tatsächlich, das machen Leute, ihre eigene Adresse eingeben. Das kommt gut.
Aber das heißt, also Datenjournalismus ist tatsächlich an der Stelle auch ein Werkzeug, wo sich Nutzerinnen und Nutzer in Beziehungen mit der Geschichte setzen können. Weil ansonsten kann man ja immer nur gucken, also, die Protagonistinnen und Protagonistinnen gleichen die mir jetzt, kann ich Sympathie einfach nachfüllen. Aber da ist es eher ein Ansatz, wo man Menschen reinziehen kann auch.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit und ich finde auch eine sehr wertvolle Möglichkeit von Datenjournalismus. Zumindest, wenn es eben diese interaktive Darstellungsform wird. Ich meine, das ist ja die Idee hinter Interaktivität. Ich kann damit in Beziehung treten und kann eben ein bisschen meine eigene Geschichte darin finden, tatsächlich. Wenn ich irgendwie einen Text lese, dann liest jeder den gleichen Text. Wenn ich aber eine interaktive Visualisierung habe, wo ich selber drin rumsuchen kann, dann suche ich mir auch so ein bisschen meine eigene Geschichte. Muss man natürlich vorsichtig mit umgehen, weil die Leute wollen auch nicht eine halbe Stunde lang auf fünf verschiedenen Ebenen rumklicken können. Also Buttons immer sehr sparsam einsetzen, aber prinzipiell klar gibt es den Leuten die Möglichkeit, ihre eigene Geschichte zu suchen.
Was machst du eigentlich mit den Daten?
Also ich würde noch ein bisschen was ergänzen zu, wenn man halt viel mit solchen Datenprojekten arbeitet. Ich greife jetzt mal das Beispiel der Bundestagswahl raus, wo wir beim Tagesspiegel einen extra Wahlportal gemacht haben, um die Wahlergebnisse darzustellen. Die meisten Daten, die wir benutzt haben, sind eigentlich gar nicht sichtbar. Die haben wir im Hintergrund gebraucht, um Daten umzurechnen, um sie in einer Karte darzustellen. Wir haben OpenStreetMap-Daten genutzt, um zu gucken, wo leben überhaupt Leute, damit wir nicht das Tempelhofer Feld einmalen, wie viele SPD-Wähler es dort gibt oder so. Also ganz viele Daten benutzen wir im Hintergrund und sind eigentlich gar nicht sichtbar vorne. Das ist so ein bisschen der Vor- und Nachteil von Open Data. Ich würde, Open Data ist eigentlich so eine Art Datengrundversorgung, die man braucht. Also es bringt mir ja nichts, irgendwie die Adressen von, was ist ich, Berliner Schulen zu wissen, wenn ich nicht mal nachschlagen kann, was ist denn die Geokoordinate dieser Schule an? Also brauche ich irgendwie eine Datenbank, um zu gucken, wo sind denn diese Adressen in Berlin genau? Und der Nachteil für Open Data entsteht dadurch, dass viele Open Data-Nutzungen gar nicht sichtbar sind. Das heißt, die Daten werden intensivst genutzt, aber derjenige, der die erstellt hat, sieht gar nicht, wo. Wo die tatsächlich eingesetzt werden. Ein schönes Beispiel, hatte ich letztens in einem Podcast Raumzeit gehört, da geht es um das Copernicus-Projekt. Das ist ein Satellitensystem der ESA, die im Prinzip die Erde umkreisen, und sie konnte nicht einscannen. So kann man das vielleicht formulieren. Und die haben vorher diese Daten versucht zu verkaufen, haben versucht, ein Geschäftsmodell zu machen. Und haben dann nach Jahrzehnten festgestellt, wir kriegen nur 0, 1% der Kosten rein, weil so ein Satellitensystem ist ja teuer, und so viel zahlen die Unternehmen halt auch nicht dafür. Und die haben jetzt diese Daten komplett als Open Data ins Identität gepackt unter sahihub.com.au, ich glaube EU oder sowas. Da kann man reinzoomen, kann sich alles Kartenmaterial angucken. Die haben seitdem, die Nutzerzahlen explodieren, sind jetzt bei 100.000 und so weiter. Und wo die eingesetzt werden, da sehen die gar nicht, ob das irgendwelche Start-up sind, ob das irgendwelche Konzerne sind, Verwaltungen, die da drinnen nachschlagen, das weiß man halt nicht. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Nachteil, dass ich die Wirkung von Open Data nicht nachprüfen kann, weil ich nicht sehe, wo es tatsächlich eingesetzt wird. Ich würde es tatsächlich als eine Grundversorgung der Gesellschaft mit Daten bezeichnen.
Aber das heißt, bei dir selber ist dann auch die Arbeit beendet, wenn du es irgendwie veröffentlichst? Also wenn du den Datensatz veröffentlichst? Oder wie sieht dein Prozess aus, wie du aus den Daten dann noch was machst? Und wie präsentierst du das?
Na also ich hatte ja auch lange Zeit als Datenjournalist gearbeitet, deswegen war da mein Prozess ganz ähnlich wie bei Kira. Dass wir die Daten genommen haben, dann oft mit anderen Daten kombiniert haben, versucht in irgendeiner ansprechenden Form zu veröffentlichen. Manchmal waren es tatsächlich Geschichten, die wir miterzählt haben. Manchmal waren es interaktive Werkzeuge, mit denen die Leute rumspielen konnten. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an das Projekt 1928.tagespiele.de. Das ist nichts weiter als eine Art Google Maps. Wenn ich dadurch Berlin laufe, kann ich mir sozusagen angucken, wie sieht Berlin aus. Aber die Karte ist zweigeteilt. Links ist es 1928, rechts ist es heute. Da sieht man ganz gut, welche Gebäude noch stehen, wie die Siegessäule verschoben wurde. Wie sah der Görlitzer Park eigentlich aus? Da soll ja mal ein Bahnhof gewesen sein. Vor dem Tagesspiegel steht so eine alte Mauer. Die habe ich nie bemerkt, bis ich irgendwann verstanden habe. Stimmt, der Anhalter Bahnhof stand ja da mal. Du hast die nie bemerkt? Ich bin da durchgelaufen und habe die nicht bemerkt. Ich bin Nerd, ich gucke mein Telefon.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, öfter mal vom Smartphone hochgucken. Komm doch mal in die Real World.
Das Tolle ist, das Smartphone hat mir jetzt gezeigt, dass da diese Mauer ist.
Ich sage jetzt, vielleicht hatte Spitzer doch recht. Okay, was ich noch fragen wollte ist, wenn der die Daten zur Verfügung stellt und selber auch schon drauf rumgedacht und rumgearbeitet hat, ist es euch schon passiert, dass dann erst durch die Interaktivität, die auch mit drin war, dass dann noch mal Dinge rausgekommen sind von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern, wo ihr dachtet so, wow, krass, das habe ich gar nicht bemerkt. Oder habt ihr so einen Nachfolgeffekt noch mal gesehen?
Beim Zugmonitor war das so, dass wir diese Daten aus der Deutschen Bahn rausgescrapt haben, sie live als Karte dargestellt haben und Wert darauf gelegt haben, dass die Daten, die wir rausgescrapt haben, noch mal irgendwo zum Runterladen anbieten. Die rechtliche Situation, unter welcher Lizenz man sie hätte veröffentlichen dürfen, war nicht ganz geklärt, aber zumindest haben wir es getan. Da gab es viele Nachfolgeprojekte daraus, z.B. Leute, die die Sinnhaftigkeit von Stuttgart 21 nachgerechnet haben, zu gucken, wie viel Verkehr tatsächlich durchging. Es gab noch zwei weitere Projekte, an die ich mich nicht erinnern kann. Aber das finde ich ganz gut, wenn man die Methoden und Daten für die journalistischen Projekte noch mal veröffentlicht. Da gibt es Folgesachen, die manchmal auch ganz hübsch sind und sinnvoll.
Mir ist es bisher noch nicht so passiert, dass jemand gesagt hat, ich habe eure Karte angeguckt und mir ist dieser eine Ort speziell aufgefallen. Würde ich mich aber total drüber freuen. Also sollte hier irgendwer zuhören. Das nächste Datenprojekt, was ihr seht, schreibt gerne den Autoren, wenn ihr irgendwas Spannendes seht. Die freuen sich, glaube ich, immer. Was ich aber schon hatte, ist, dass tatsächlich auch hinterher Wissenschaftler gekommen sind, der Redaktion geschrieben haben und gesagt haben, so etwas ganz Ähnliches wollte ich auch mal machen, habe ich auch schon mal gemacht. Könnt ihr da nochmal die Methodik erklären? Könnt ihr da nochmal irgendwie vielleicht Zugang zu den Daten geben? Und sowas freut uns natürlich immer. Schön wäre es natürlich, wenn man sich dann vorher vielleicht sogar trifft und sich sogar austauschen kann. Aber wenn man sich da gegenseitig dadurch weiterhelfen kann, ist das super.
Wir hatten übrigens, wenn mir noch ein, bei der Tegel-Befragung, die parallel zur Bundestagswahl lief, hatten wir die grafisch dargestellt und hatten ein Wahlbüro gefunden, das offensichtlich falsche Ergebnisse ausgeworfen hat und konnten das wieder zurückspielen an die statistischen Ämter, um die Wahl ohne nochmal zu prüfen.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, in dem, wie ihr das macht, ist das schon eher eine Präsentation. Also ja, man kann da irgendwie drin rumklicken und so, das ist auch nice, aber das ist erstmal ein Aussenden, diese Information auf eine andere Art und Weise, wie wir es gewohnt sind, aber von one way, mehr oder weniger.
In vielen Fällen schon. Also es ist natürlich, es ist einfach eine journalistische Sache. Es ist häufig im Journalismus so, dass es auch immer noch viel so gedacht wird. Okay, wir produzieren unsere Inhalte, wir präsentieren die so und das war's. Aber, und darüber freue ich mich auch, dass es auch immer mehr Initiativen gibt, zu versuchen, ein bisschen in Interaktion mit dem Publikum zu treten. Das ist aber nichts, was jetzt, also in meiner Erfahrung nicht so spezifisch für den Datenjournalismus ist, sondern einfach generell es Initiativen im Journalismus gibt, zu sagen, komm, wir treten mal in Dialog. Was interessiert unsere Leser eigentlich wirklich? Wie ist diese Geschichte angekommen? Wie können wir Feedback vom Publikum zu einer Geschichte irgendwie vielleicht nochmal einarbeiten?
Ich will jetzt gerne noch zwei Probleme beleuchten oder Dinge, wo ich mich frage, ob das Probleme sein können. Das eine ist, oder es hat beides damit zu tun, dass ihr ja nicht nur sozusagen eine Datenquelle nehmt und dann sozusagen die verarbeitet, sondern auch Daten miteinander kombiniert und auch daraus Dinge versteht. Das eine ist ja, es gibt ja dieses Schöne, dass man Korrelationen mit Kausalität nicht verwechseln sollen, also nur weil, keine Ahnung, die Kurve der Pflaumenernte und die Kurve der Meteoriteneinschläge gleichzeitig nach oben geht. Das bedeutet nicht zwangsweise, dass Pflaumen Meteoriten sind. Wie schützt man sich vor sowas?
Passiert das? Das ist ja das, was ich vorhin auch meinte. Man ist als Journalist vielleicht schon, aber meistens kein ausgewöhneter Statistiker zum Beispiel. Das heißt, sowas passiert definitiv. Und da ist es, finde ich, wichtig, dass gerade jeder, der datenjournalistisch arbeitet, mein wegen aber auch gerne wirklich jeder, der journalistisch arbeitet, ein bisschen genug Grundwissen in Statistik hat, um zu wissen, was komplex ist. Also einfach, um zu wissen, okay, hier, ich habe doch mal das gehört mit Korrelation und Kausalität. Wenn ich mir nicht sicher bin, dann frage ich vielleicht noch mal nach bei einem Wissenschaftler vom Fach oder bei einem Statistiker.
Das fällt mir relativ oft im Journalismus auf. Und das finde ich ganz gut, dass es jetzt mehr Datenjournalisten in Redaktionen gibt, die dieses Wissen auch einfach weitergeben, dass eine Korrelation nicht ausmarsch-kausalität ist.
Ja, aber die Frage geht schon ein bisschen weiter. Ihr denkt, ihr macht aber was mit den Daten. Kann man immer sichergehen, der Schluss, den ich jetzt daraus ziehe, ist auch wirklich der richtige?
Also komplett sichergehen kann man natürlich nicht. Man kann mit ein bisschen Common Sense auf jeden Fall dran gehen. Und es gibt im Journalismus einfach auch ein bisschen Qualitätssicherungsmethoden, die wir auf jeden Fall anwenden müssen. Also dann schauen wir halt irgendwie so ein bisschen, wir gucken uns Stichproben aus den Daten an und schauen, ist das plausibel, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel geografische Daten hat auf Berlin-Ebene, ist das schon passiert, dass ich die Daten irgendwie mal auf eine Karte geworfen habe und eine Kollegin, die daneben stand, sagt im Moment, nee in Schöneberg, da wohne ich aber. Das weiß ich aber ganz sicher, dass der Punkt da nicht hingehört. Sowas hilft auch einfach wirklich mehrere Augen drüber gucken zu lassen. Häufig ist man einfach so in seinem Arbeitsablauf drin, dass man manche Fehler gar nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe dafür einen Test, der lässt sich auch ganz leicht merken. Den nenne ich einfach jetzt mal ABBACAB-Test. Der Trick besteht darin, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie zwei Sachen habe, A und B, und ich will jetzt wissen, es gibt irgendwie eine Korrelation dazwischen. Wie ich wissen, gibt es dann auch eine Kausalität dahinter. Und dann kann man sagen, wenn es irgendwo eine Korrelation zwischen zwei Sachen gibt, gibt es immer drei Möglichkeiten, wie die Kausalität entstehen kann. Aus A folgt B, aus B folgt A, oder es gibt ein unbekanntes C, aus dem A und B folgt. Wenn ich das jetzt mal durchgehe, schnell durchlaufe, verheiratete Menschen leben länger, dann heißt das, wenn Leute verheiratet sind, leben sie länger. Kann gut sein, weil ich kümmere mich lieber um meine Familie, statt mit einem schnellen Motorrad zu fahren. Ich kann auch gucken, geht es andersherum, wer länger lebt, ist verheiratet. Stimmt, wer zum Beispiel mit 17 bei einem Motorradunfall ums Leben kommt, hat da nicht mehr die Chance zu heiraten. Oder die dritte Variante, es gibt was Unbekanntes, aus dem A und B folgt, beispielsweise, ich habe eine schwere Krankheit, ich habe Krebs oder so was. Das sorgt dafür, dass ich zum einen Schwierigkeiten habe, vielleicht einen Lebenspartner zu finden und zum anderen lange zu leben. Und wenn man das bei einer Korrelation einfach sich durchgeht, diese drei Varianten kann man halt gucken, ob man vielleicht auch noch auf andere mögliche Ursachen stößt und ob diese Korrelation wirklich aussagefähig ist oder nicht.
Wie oft ist es auch passiert, dass ihr in der Geschichte, es gibt diesen Begriff Tod recherchiert habt, also dass man, man hat eine These, man geht hin, zieht die Daten und denkt so, ja, nee, das war es nicht.
Passiert, also passiert auch, passiert immer mal wieder. Also wo ich mich auch ein bisschen geärgert hat, weil ich wirklich dachte, das wäre eine gute Geschichte. Ich war letztes Jahr bei der Times in London mal zum Praktikum. Und das hatte ich mir noch mal genau angeschaut. Ich hatte mir angeguckt, Spenden von Pharmaunternehmen an Ärzte. Das ist auf EU-Ebene, glaube ich, eine Datenbank. Und welche Medikamente diese Ärzte verschreiben. Da gibt es nämlich großartige, offene Daten vom NHS, vom National Health Service, also dem Gesundheitssystem in der UK. Und ich war mir so sicher, es muss doch irgendwie drin zu sehen sein, wenn dieser Arzt super viel Geld von irgendeinem Pharmaunternehmen bekommen hat. Dann verschreibt er doch bestimmt mehr Medikamente von diesem Pharmaunternehmen. Und ich habe zwei Tage daran rumgeschrieben. Ich habe es aus allen Winkeln betrachtet. Ich wollte wirklich, dass da irgendwas ist, aber da war nicht mal eine Korrelation da, die man mit Kausalität verwechseln könnte. Ich habe mich so geärgert. Passiert.
Ja, ist das ein Problem? Spätestens, wenn man das für Geld macht, dann verwendet man ja Arbeitszeit, um herauszufinden, dass es doch nicht so ist.
Also ich hatte da das zweifelhafte Glück, gar nicht bezahlt zu werden. Ich war Praktikantin, da wird man nicht bezahlt. Das ist eine Ehre. Nein, es ist natürlich irgendwie ein Problem. Ich glaube, es ist weniger ein Problem, wenn du fest in der Redaktion arbeitest oder zumindest fest die Zeit sowieso eingeplant hast. Es ist vielleicht tatsächlich mehr ein Problem, wenn du als freier Journalist Geschichten recherchierst, die du dann Medien anbieten möchtest. Weil dann hast du da irgendwie drei Tage Arbeit reingesteckt, wirst aber gar nicht bezahlt, weil keine Geschichte da ist.
Aber das ist sozusagen, wie bei vielen Sachen, anscheinend dann auch so, dass es theoretisch eigentlich besser ist. Redaktionen würden sich Datenjournalisten halten.
Nein, ist das Wort.
Also sagen, würden Menschen dafür bezahlen, einen totalen Datenjournalismus zu betreiben, und zwar unabhängig davon, ob dann das Story rausfällt oder nicht?
Also ich bin total dafür, uns zu bezahlen.
Ich meine, es gibt immer dieses Freelancer vs. Fest. Und als fester Redakteur oder fester Journalist oder Journalistin kannst du sie halt eher leisten zu sagen, ne, die Geschichte gibt einfach nichts her, lass uns das nicht machen. Und dann verdienst du trotzdem Geld. Und als Freelancer oder Freelancerin ist ja das Problem einfach, wenn du sagst, ich habe recherchiert dieses Thema, was wir zusammen geplant haben, aber das ist halt einfach nix, dann kriegst du halt auch nix.
Ja, das ist glaube ich kein spezifisches Datenjournalistisches Problem. Also auch Freijournalisten, die andere Geschichten recherchieren, denen kann es passieren, dass es platt ist.
Das ist schon klar, aber ich frage mich sozusagen, wenn man in den Daten drin ist, ob dann die Versuchung vielleicht höher ist, zu sagen, ja da kann ich aber, wenn ich die Kurve da so hinschiebe, dann sieht das schon extrem krass aus.
Also das muss man sagen, also die Versuchung ist da. Ich hoffe von mir behaupten zu können, dass ich dem nicht nachgebe. Die Versuchung ist definitiv da und ich denke, dass die bestimmt größer ist, wenn man einfach ökonomischen Druck dahinter hat. Selbst ohne ist es häufig so. Ich hatte auch schon eine ähnliche Geschichte, und der Redakteur wirklich drei Tage hintereinander nachgefragt hat, bitte guckst du dir noch mal aus dem anderen Blick an, ich bin mir so sicher und ich nur erzählt habe, es ist nichts da. Es ist da einfach nichts.
Ich finde ja einfach als Zuschauer, als Leser auch Geschichten spannend, wo jemand schreibt, ich habe nachgeguckt und ich habe nichts gefunden. Und das wird viel zu wenig gemacht, finde ich, weil das trotzdem total spannende Geschichten sein können.
Ja, das muss ich richtig nehmen. Aber dich wollte ich jetzt hier auch noch fragen. Du hast ja am Anfang der Sendung gesagt, deine Motivation ist oft so ein, da stimmt was nicht. Und du hast auch erzählt, es ist nicht so einfach, an die Daten ranzukommen. Und da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass man auch sozusagen in so eine Falle laufen kann, dass man denkt, man hat dieses ganz starke Gefühl und es ist schwer, an die Daten ranzukommen. Jetzt hat man vielleicht ein Datum, was sagt, haha, ich habe recht. Woher weißt du denn, dass du genug hast? Also woher weißt du denn, dass du wirklich alles, was verfügbar ist, da hast?
Ich habe nie genug.
Ok, verstehe. Also Datenaktivist ist ein Merkmal, was man unbedingt haben muss. Nie genug Daten haben. Die andere Sache, die ich euch noch fragen wollte, ist, wenn wir über soziale Netzwerke reden und über Ad-Tracking im Netz, also wo wir irgendwie alle verfolgt werden, da ist ja die Warnung, die wir machen, oder die halt immer gesagt wird, ist, naja, da werden halt Daten miteinander kombiniert, die echt krasse Aussagen zulassen, die du vielleicht eigentlich gar nicht willst. Du willst gar nicht, dass dich eine Firma oder ein Werbetracker so genau kennt, wie die das können, weil die verschiedene Datenquellen kombinieren. Natürlich hellhörig, weil ein großer Teil eurer Arbeit ist es, Datenquellen zu kombinieren. Ist es eine Gefahr, dass da Dinge passieren können, dass ihr Daten miteinander kombiniert und an die Öffentlichkeit geben, die dann Effekte haben, die nicht wünschenswert sind? Ich versuche mir ein Beispiel auszudenken. Was erzählt das? Düsseldorf, wo kommen die Leute her? Dass man da was über einzelne Menschen herausfinden kann oder Dinge herausfinden kann, die vielleicht gefährlich sind?
Das Beispiel ist dafür gar nicht so schlecht. Prinzipiell kann das natürlich passieren. Da muss man vorsichtig sein. Aber da gibt es in Deutschland keinen schlechten Datenschutz, wie das hinter den Kulissen aussieht. Aber die Daten, die in die Öffentlichkeit kommen, die sind in den allermeisten Fällen genügend anonymisiert. Beispielsweise bei der Geschichte, woher die Düsseldorfer kommen, hatten wir nur Orte, aus denen mindestens 100 Menschen kommen. Bei 100 Menschen ist es extrem schwer, herauszufinden, das ist doch der Kevin von nebenan aus Marokko, den kenne ich doch. Das ist da nicht so das Problem. In kleineren Kommunen, die sowieso nur 5.000 Einwohner haben, passiert es schneller mal, dass die Daten auch auf sehr niedrigschwelligem Niveau verfügbar sind. Dann ist halt einfach die journalistische Ethik gefragt. Wie anonymisieren wir die Daten so, dass man das eben nicht machen kann. Das ist dann nicht das Ziel der Sache, der Sinn der Sache.
Arne, habt ihr schon mal irgendwie Daten nie genug Daten bekommen und die natürlich auch an alle weitergehen, wo ihr nachher so gedacht habt, naja, vielleicht war das möglicherweise doch keine so gute Idee.
Nicht direkt so, aber natürlich sind Datenschutzprobleme immer mal wieder da. Aber aus einem anderen Grund vor allem, in der Zusammenarbeit oder wie auch immer gegen die Behörden, wenn es Datenschutzprobleme gibt, wenn also mehr personenbezogene Daten an die Öffentlichkeit kommen als sie sollten, dann ist das meiner Erfahrung nach in der Regel der Fall, weil die Medienkompetenz der zuständigen Behördenmitarbeiter nicht hoch genug ist. Heißt, eine Excel-Datei und dann wird statt eine Spalte zu löschen, die Spalte verborgen und sie ist immer noch drin. Solche Sachen sind eher Grund dafür, dass gerade so in diesem Open Data Bereich Daten an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, die es nicht sollten, als dass da jetzt irgendwie absichtlich zu viel veröffentlicht wird.
Sind Metadaten ein Problem? Also es gibt gerade Excel-Tabellen zum Beispiel enthalten, nicht nur das, was man sieht, wenn man es aufmacht. Da drin stecken immer noch so Sachen, wie welches Betriebssystem, wie heißt der User und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es da Dinge?
Ist eh meistens Windows 7.
Aber führt ihr da eine Bereinigung durch, wenn ihr die Daten aufarbeitet?
Nee, das ist in der Regel dann, wenn es um Behörden geht, die Aufgabe der Behörde.
Das klingt nach einem interessanten datenschulistischen Projekt, oder? Alle PDFs von Kleine Anfragen.de Kommt raus überall Windows 7.
Na gut, wir machen jetzt noch eine kleine Pause. Es gibt noch eine Runde Nerd News und danach geben wir die letzte Runde. Da würde ich von euch mal gerne wissen wollen, was denn so die nächsten Projekte sind. Aber wie gesagt, erstmal eine kleine Runde Nerd News.
Der Internet-Pionier John Perry Barlow ist an Herzversagen gestorben. Barlow schrieb Songs für die Band Grateful Dead und setzte sich für Meinungsfreiheit und andere Bürgerrechte ein. Er verfasste 1996 die Unabhängigkeitserklärung des Cyberspace, die sich gegen die staatliche Kontrolle über das Internet wendet. Barlow ist vor allem als Gründer der Electronic Frontier Foundation und der Freedom of the Press Foundation bekannt. Die Whistle Blow, wie Edward Snowden und Chelsea Manning unterstützt und Schutzsoftware wie SecureDrop und Haven entwickelte. FitnessTracker verrät geheime Militärinformationen Eine Weltkarte des FitnessTrackers Strava enthielt seit 2015 vertrauliche militärische Nutzerdaten. Die Global Heatmap zeigte mehr als eine Milliarde Aktivitäten der Strava-Nutzer der letzten Jahre, die von ihnen selbst mit Trackern automatisch aufgezeichnet wurden. Weil zu den Nutzern offensichtlich viele Soldaten gehörten, konnte die Position geheimer Militärbasen aufgedeckt werden. Außerdem war es möglich, die Soldaten in ihre Heimat zurückzuverfolgen und zu deanonymisieren. Open Schufa will Scoring transparent machen. Das Crowdfunding-Projekt Open Schufa versucht herauszufinden, wie die Bonitätsauskunft bei Schufa ihr Scoring ermittelt. Der Score wird bei Ratenkäufen und anderen Vertragsabschlüssen zur Ermittlung der Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit von Zahlungen verwendet. Die Berechnungsmethode gilt als Betriebsgeheimnis und die Qualität der zugrundeliegenden Daten ist nicht bekannt. Open Schufa hofft, die Methoden und gegebenenfalls systemische Fehler der Scoringfirma offenlegen zu können und bittet dazu um Datenspenden von Schufa-Auskünften. Unterstützt wird Open Schufa von AlgorithmWatch, der Open Knowledge Foundation und Geldspenden.
New Retrowave von Data Fatale hier im Chaosradio 243, wo wir auf die Zielgerade der letzten halben Stunde einbiegen. Also ein bisschen radiosprechend muss auch mal sein. So, wir haben eine Zuschauer, Zuhörer oder Zuhörerinnen Frage, nämlich ist eine Fachfrage, bitte halten sie sich kurz oder verweisen sie auf Quellen. Was empfiehlt ihr für ein Framework, um Daten irgendwo rauszuziehen, Python-Request oder gibt es da grafische Tools, die einen das Leben vereinfachen? Könnt ihr, bevor ihr die Frage beantwortet, mir erklären, was die Frage bedeutet?
Ich müsste raten, aber ich würde raten, dass es um Scraping geht, Daten irgendwo rauszuziehen.
Also diese Webseiten danach untersuchen, was, wie man die Daten gibt. Gibt es eine Standardempfehlung? Gibt es einen Standardroboter, den man ins Web schicken kann?
Also, äh...
Gerüchteweise gibt es irgendwelche Browserplugins, die das auch können, aber ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht die Namen.
Da wirft man eine URL rein und dann zeigt die einem sozusagen an, was Datenpunkte sein könnten oder wie funktioniert das?
Bisschen komplexer als das, ja. Aber Webscraper ist zum Beispiel ein schön dokumentiertes Projekt, wo man schön reinkommt in Scraping. Also damit kann sogar ich Scrapen.
Also gut, du machst das jetzt professionell mit der Datensammlung. Gibt es so ein Ding für Leute, die anziehen? Also gibt es so etwas, was einem mal visualisiert, was so diese Struktur an der Webseite ist und wo man da Daten rausziehen könnte?
Also womit das relativ einfach geht, auch garantiert ohne Programmieren, ist import.io. Das hat kostenpflichtige Accounts, hat aber ein bisschen versteckt, aber man findet auch einen Studierenden, also einen Bildungsaccount auf jeden Fall. Der ist dann kostenlos und testen kann man es auch. Und das hat tatsächlich eine relativ einfache grafische Oberfläche. Und beim Scraping läuft das halt so, man muss sich ein bisschen die Struktur der Website durchgucken und schauen, an welchem Punkt der Struktur stehen die Daten drin, die ich haben will. Und import.io hilft einem dabei und visualisiert das ein bisschen schön grafisch und man kann irgendwie auf Dinge draufklicken, statt dass man Code schreiben muss.
Okay, das klingt ganz interessant und ist ja vielleicht auch ganz lehrreich, selbst wenn man kein Scraping macht, um mal ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, was eigentlich Webseite bedeutet. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch von euch wissen, was so das nächste Zukunftsprojekt ist. Wir hatten ja ein, zwei Mal schon den NerdNews genannt, wo die Open Schufa, da hängt der Herr Semsrott auch mit drin. Explainify.
Die Schufa ist ein wahnsinnig mächtiges Unternehmen, das wahnsinnig viele Daten hat. 813 Millionen Datensätze über 70 Millionen Bürger in Deutschland. Und damit eine enorme Macht über den Alltag von all diesen Menschen.
Ich tendiere im Chaosradio immer zu sagen, Schufa ist das Einzige, wo ich denke, das muss man nicht erklären. Weil die jeder hat schon mal damit zu tun gehabt, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich damit zu tun haben müssen dann sogar. Mindestens, wenn man einen Mietvertrag haben wollte. Aber der Algorithmus dahinter, also die Frage, wie kommt denn die Schufa eigentlich zu ihrem Score? Die ist ein Geschäftsgeheimnis. Und das wollen wir ein bisschen knacken. Wir wollen die Mechanismen hinter diesem Algorithmus freilegen. Und dazu suchen wir vor allem Datenspenden. Das heißt, die Idee hinter dem Schufa ist, dass alle Menschen ihre Schufa-Auskunft anfragen. Das ist dann in der Regel eine lange große Tabelle mit Prozentzahlen und ein paar Zeichen. Und dann diese Tabelle an uns spenden. Das heißt, einscannen über ein Tool, das wir noch entwickeln müssen. Und über diese Datenpunkte, die wir dann sammeln, also sagen wir mal, 10.000 Leute geben uns diese Tabelle, geben uns dann freiwillig dazu noch ein paar mehr Angaben über zum Beispiel Einkommensgruppe oder über Postgleitzahlgebiet, in dem sie wohnen. Und dann können wir mit all diesen Daten, die wir sammeln, Abhängigkeiten innerhalb dieser Werte finden. Das heißt, wir können idealerweise, wenn alles super läuft, die Frage beantworten, diskriminiert die Schufa. Macht es einen Unterschied, ob ich im Norden oder Süden der Stadt wohne? Macht es einen Unterschied, ob ich Mann bin oder Frau? Was sind die einzelnen Datenpunkte, die diesen Scoringwert von der Schufa beeinflussen?
Wenn man das verfolgt, dann klingt das so, ihr wollt die Schufa-Formel reverse-engineeren, also quasi dazu, die wirklich sozusagen hinkriegen. Ist das wirklich das Ziel, am Ende diese Formel habt? Oder geht es eher darum zu sagen, wir haben so bestimmte What-the-fuck-Moment-Verdachte und wir wollen einmal nachprüfen, ob das sich irgendwie zeigt?
Also, die exakte Formel, die werden wir sicher nicht schaffen, weil wir dazu noch viel, viel mehr Daten sammeln müssen. Das können wir nicht machen. Aber ich glaube, wir können auf jeden Fall in die Richtung gehen, dass wir so bestimmte Hypothesen testen, dass wir zumindest rausfinden, was besonders wichtige Datenpunkte sind. Und ich stelle mir das so vor, dass am Schluss vielleicht eine sehr simple Formel dabei rumkommt. Aber vor allem ein Portal, wo man eingeben kann, das ist das Einkommen und ich bin Mann oder Frau und da wohne ich. Und dann kriegt man so ungefähr einen Schuferscore raus. Und dann kann ich ein bisschen rumspielen. Jetzt bin ich nicht mehr Mann, sondern Frau. Was macht das mit dem Schuferscore und so weiter? Das wäre die Ideallösung dabei. Aber wir brauchen halt die Mithilfe von möglichst vielen Leuten, die ihre Daten an uns spenden. Und das ist so was ziemlich Neues. Das gab es, glaube ich, zumindest in Deutschland so noch nicht. Und wir probieren das mal aus und schauen, wie das klappt.
Gibt es das? Ihr habt ja auch gerade so ein Crowdfunding zu laufen. Das ist, um das Tool zu schreiben, um diese Daten dann einzulesen.
Genau, also wir müssen es möglichst einfach machen, diese Daten zu spenden. Das ist so das eine. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie man es danach darstellt und so. Und dafür sammeln wir insgesamt 50.000 Euro. Jetzt sind wir bei 29.221 Euro. Ich bin minütlich auf dieser Startnext-Seite. Und reloade die die ganze Zeit. Ja, und wir hoffen, dass wir da die volle Summe zusammenkriegen.
Nach allem, was ihr mir erzählt habt in der Sendung, vermute ich, dass Schufa-Mitarbeiter da auch reichhaltig spenden.
Vielleicht ja von der Schufa-Konkurrenz, ist nicht so klar.
Apropos Konkurrenz, da kommen wir gleich drauf. Was ich jetzt tatsächlich vorher noch fragen wollte, ist... Nee, genau das doch. Die Schufa hat ja sozusagen auch darauf geantwortet. Ein sehr langes Schreiben. Der Wirtschaftsstaat Deutschland ist in Gefahr, wenn man da irgendwie drankommt. Und es ist auch ganz gefährlich, euch die Daten zu geben. Ihr seid ja ganz schlimme Verbrecher auch. Steht da nicht drin. Habe ich jetzt frei zwischen den Zeilen lesen paraphrasiert. Da findet aber schon Angstmacherei auch statt. Was passieren kann, wenn man die Daten an unbefugte Dritte geht. Aber der eine interessante Punkt, der man als Frage stellen kann, ist, die Schufa ist zwar das, was wir alle kennen, aber bei Weitem nicht die einzige Scoring-Firma in Deutschland. Es gibt auch eine andere, die heißt Avato. Die wiederum gehört zu Bertelsmann. Bertelsmann wiederum gibt Geld an AlgorithmWatch.
Bertelsmann-Schiftung. Bertelsmann gehört zur Bertelsmann-Schiftung.
Okay, einen Schritt über mein Bad. Zum Glück sind die Daten alle da. Und AlgorithmWatch ist wiederum euer Partner bei OpenShufa. Und die Frage, die die Shufa dargestellt hat, ist so, naja, das ist aber schon komisch, dass sie nur auf uns zeigt und nicht auf die Konkurrenz, wo über OpenWege auch Geld kommt.
Ja, also erst mal muss ich sagen, diese Stellungnahme, die die Shufa abgegeben hat, die war eine Woche lang prominent auf der Startseite von der Shufa verlinkt. Das war super. Das war die beste Werbung, die wir so haben konnten für das Projekt. Danke an die PR-Abteilung an dieser Stelle. Und zwar ins Ja, stimmt, die Battlesman-Stiftung gibt Geld an Algorithm Watch, nicht für dieses Projekt, aber zur Grundfinanzierung von der Organisation. Aber das heißt überhaupt nicht, dass wir uns nicht mit Avato Info Score beschäftigen. Ganz im Gegenteil, die ganzen Auskunftsanfragen nach den eigenen Daten, die gehen jetzt gerade nicht nur an die Shufa, sondern die gehen über das Portal, das wir nutzen, auskunft.net, auch an Avato Info Score zum Beispiel. In den letzten Tagen haben ein paar Tausend Leute auch da ihre Auskunft angefragt. Und idealerweise können wir am Schluss das Tool, das wir für die Shufa benutzen, auch für andere Auskunft, Auskunftteilen benutzen. Das heißt, natürlich muss nicht nur die Shufa transparenter werden, sondern all diese Auskunftteilen.
Aber es heißt ja Open Shufa, nicht Open Scoring-Unternehmen.
Die Shufa ist der Marktführer, die haben die meisten Daten. Natürlich fangen wir mit denen an. Aber mit denen müssen wir ja nicht aufhören. Das Crowdfunding geht noch 21 Tage. Und dann wollen wir im Mai die Software fertig haben und dann bis Juni schon die ersten Daten ausgewertet haben.
Was, es gibt ja, also von Computerspielen und Crowdfunding geht das so, wenn ihr doppelt so viel spendet, dann dürft ihr möglicherweise auch einen weiblichen Charakter spielen. Habt ihr auch so Bonusziele oder ist das eher so, ihr macht bei 50.000 zu, weil das reicht dann?
Ja, okay, wahrscheinlich weiß ich zu wenig über das Crowdfunding. Bitte spendet.
Nein, ich meine, es gibt ja sozusagen, es gibt ja manche Kicks, also Crowdfunding-Unternehmen, sagen ja, also wenn wir brauchen so und so viel, aber wenn das und das mehr kommt, dann machen wir noch das und das. Habt ihr auch so was? Also wir brauchen eigentlich 50, aber wenn wir bis 75 kommen, dann bauen wir auch gleich die Erwartungsschiene oder irgendwie so.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt nicht gesagt, weil es nicht so clever ist. Das erste Fundingziel ist 30.000. Das heißt, da fehlen uns jetzt noch 800 Euro. Und danach müssen wir auf 50.000 kommen. Dass wir zum Beispiel noch externe Experten hinzuziehen können und bezahlen können. Also ein paar Statistiker, die Modelle bei Banken bauen.
Das haben wir heute gelernt, so gute Statistiker dabei zu haben.
Genau. Und dass wir das alles ein bisschen hübscher machen können und so.
Na gut, kann man ja machen. Sehr schön. Und dann ist im Sommer, können wir alle gucken, was unser Score ist. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt. Spendet Daten, spendet Geld, ist eine gute Sache. Wahrscheinlich.
Kira, dein nächstes Projekt? Wir waren eben schon kurz beim Thema Konkurrenz. Deswegen, also für Journalisten ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig, über nächste Projekte zu sprechen. Open Data. Ich wünschte auch, es wäre anders, wirklich. Aber ich kann definitiv eins nennen, was mir seit Jahren im Kopf rumschwört, weil das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird. Aber ich bin nicht bereit, die Hoffnung aufzugeben, mal das Thema Obdachlosigkeit aus Datenperspektive zu beleuchten. Auch übrigens finde ich ein Thema, wo man überhaupt mal erst mal den Staat dazu bringen könnte, Daten zu erheben und die dann zu veröffentlichen, weil da die Datenlage wirklich katastrophal ist. Ich komme aus NRW, das ist das einzige Land, was überhaupt eine Statistik darüber führt, obwohl es Studien gibt, die sagen, es wäre möglich, das zu erheben. Ich habe mir die Statistik in NRW schon länger mal angeguckt. Die Definitionen gehen leider völlig an der Realität vorbei. Ich saß dann im Büro der Stadt und da sagte mir der nette Mitarbeiter, wie Obdachlose, die gibt es hier nicht. Ich dachte mir, das kann aber irgendwie auch nicht so richtig sein. Aber ich habe die Hoffnung noch nicht aufgegeben, da mal ein bisschen nach Daten zu gucken und das Thema so ein bisschen aufzubereiten.
Aber was ist die Hoffnung dahinter? Möchtest du einfach, dass man das auch auf eine etwas greifbare Form visualisieren kann, die sozusagen nicht irgendwie das bedrückende Foto ist?
Ja, exakt das. Das Thema Obdachlosigkeit ist, finde ich, ein extrem komplexes und ein extrem emotionalisiertes und eins, wo kaum jemand wirklich einen objektiven Pack an dran hat. Niemand hat eine Ahnung, wie viele Obdachlose es wirklich gibt. Es gab letztens die Nachricht, das wären irgendwie über eine Million in Deutschland. Das sind sehr grobe Schätzungen letzten Endes, schwer zu schätzen. Es gibt wenig Vorstellungen davon, wie der Alltag von solchen Menschen überhaupt aussieht. Zumindest nicht, was über einzelne Porträts hinausgeht, die häufig eben sehr emotional sind, sehr auf irgendwie entweder, oh, der Mensch ist total inspirierend oder, oh, Gottseidank, geht es mir nicht so schlecht, hinauslaufen. Das würde ich gerne mal aus einer anderen Perspektive erzählen.
Wo du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, du willst über die Projekte, die möglicherweise Erfolg haben, nicht reden. Ich frage mich, ist das so, also gerade wenn es um Daten geht, die sind ja, also Objektivität ist immer so eine schwierige Sache, aber es gibt ja Daten und die liegen auf der Hand und dann liegen vielleicht auch Interpretationen auf der Hand. Ist dir schon mal passiert, dass du sozusagen so, fuck, die Idee hatte ich auch.
Ja, absolut, also das passiert auch einfach und ich glaube, das passiert Datenjournalisten sehr viel häufiger als auch Journalisten aus anderen Ressorts, weil wenn du aus dem tagesaktuellen Berichtest ja, okay, dann hat der Martin Schulz halt gerade nur mal was gesagt, das ist okay, da berichtet jetzt halt wirklich jeder drüber, ist auch in Ordnung, wenn die Leute über das Gleiche schreiben, aber Datenjournalismus hat häufig eben so auch ein bisschen längerfristige Themen, ein bisschen zeitlosere Themen und da passiert es, dass du am gleichen Thema lange arbeitest. Also eine Art von Beispiel wäre die Bundestagswahl, da haben wirklich alle Datenteams in Deutschland sich aufs gleiche Thema gestürzt, das war aber immerhin allen vorher klar, dass da das gleiche passieren würde. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel letztens, da hat Zeit Online eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte rausgebracht, die haben Straßennamen in Deutschland analysiert, haben sich zum Beispiel angeguckt, wie unterscheiden die sich in Ost- und Westdeutschland, in Nord- und Süddeutschland, nach wem benennen wir eigentlich unsere Straßen, wer sind die Leute, nach denen wir diese Ehre irgendwie zuteilassen wollen, viele verben jetzt hier drin, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein kompletter Satz war. Wirklich schönes Projekt, wirklich schön visualisiert und ich hätte mir den Hintern beißen können. Ich wollte dieses Projekt nämlich seit zwei Jahren machen, hab mich total geärgert, ich konnte auch wirklich nur ein paar Mal einen kurzen Blick drauf werfen, da musste ich sie dazu machen. Hab mich dann bei Freunden dann darüber beschwert und drei von denen meinten, ach ja, das wollten wir auch schon mal machen, ach ja, wir hatten schon mal mit der Recherche angefangen. Also ja, es gibt naheliegende Daten und ja, das ist einfach ärgerlich, wenn sowas passiert, nichts zu machen.
Verstehe. Michael, kannst du noch etwas zur Zukunft deines Datenwissenschaftsjournalismus sagen?
Natürlich nicht, ich hab genau das gleiche Problem. Das ist schwierig sozusagen schon vorher Ideen zu veröffentlichen, weil dann, es ist ja irgendwie doof, wenn man dann Zeit reinsteckt, sondern dann ist jemand eine Woche vorher das raushaut oder sowas, dann ist man ja halt nur Nummer zwei, ist irgendwie doof. Eine Sache, die mir schon länger vorschwebt, ist das Problem, Open Data da in Deutschland die Unternehmen und die Behörden davon zu überzeugen und bei diesem Raumzeit-Podcast, als es um Copernicus ging, fand ich sehr interessant, dass sie darüber gesprochen haben, dass eines der stärksten Motivationen war, dass die NASA bereits Open Data macht und deswegen die ESA sich da eine Scheibe von abgeschnitten hat. Ich finde das ganz interessant, mal den internationalen Open Data Stand sich anzuschauen, welche Apps gibt es da draus, welche Services gibt es da und zu vergleichen, warum es die in Deutschland nicht gibt und dann vielleicht auch mal den Finger zu zeigen, hier du Verkehrsunternehmen behinderst uns da dran, dass wir so eine Apps machen können oder diese Behörde oder Verwaltung und so weiter. Da wirklich mal eine systematische, wie heißt das, Inventur zu machen, wie da der aktuelle Zustand ist, denn der ist nicht so schön wie im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern.
Gibt es denn ganz konkret noch Datenquellen, wo ihr sagt, okay, da möchten wir jetzt unbedingt dran, also über die wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen haben?
Mir fiel gerade mit dem Vergleich mit anderen Ländern ein. In den USA war es zumindest unter Obama immer üblich, dass das Besucherregister des Weißen Hauses öffentlich einsehbar war. Und das war Open Data und das war so ganz selbstverständlich und dann hat Donald Trump gesagt, okay, also ich glaube, eins der ersten Sachen, die er gemacht hat, ist, dieses Besucherregister wieder abzuschaffen. Und dann war großer Aufschrei und auch hierzulande, ah, kann er noch nicht machen, der Trump, aber niemand hat gefragt, wie ist denn hier. Es gibt kein Besucherregister vom Bundeskanzleramt, das öffentlich einsehbar ist. Und ich glaube, das wäre ein sehr interessanter Datensatz zu schauen, wer da so vorbeikommt, wer da vielleicht mal eine Geburtstagsfeier im Kanzleramt feiert, ist ja durchaus schon mal vorgekommen, der Deutsche Bank. Chef hat das ja zu seinem 60. gemacht.
Ja, genau, also ich hätte ja gerade schon gesagt, ich hätte die obdachlose Statistik wirklich gerne, dafür muss sie aber erst mal erhoben werden und erst mal entwickelt werden. Also was ich, ich habe jetzt keinen spezifischen Datensatz, aber was ich wirklich, wirklich schön fände ist, wenn, wenn es halbwegs einheitliches Datenportal für lokale Daten gäbe. Also es gibt, ich bin unglaublich dankbar über die Regionalstatistik von, von den statistischen Ämtern des Bundes und der, und der Länder, aber ich glaube einzelne Städte haben, sitzen auf solchen Datenschätzen und die irgendwie mal einheitlich hochzuladen, einfach damit man zumindest ein Grundlevel hat an, dass hier sind die Gebäude, so alt sind die Gebäude, so und so viele Leute leben an dieser Straße, in dieser Ecke der Stadt. Das müssen keine abgefahrene Datensätze sein, aber so eine Grundversorgung wäre wirklich schön.
Arne, korrigier mich, kann das sein, dass die Postleitzahlgebiete in Deutschland gar kein Open Data sind, sondern dass sie der deutschen Post gehören und dass du da richtig viel Geld bezahlen musst, um zu wissen, wo die Postleitzahlgebiete in Deutschland anfangen zu enden?
Ohne es zu wissen, würde ich dir erstmal zustimmen, ja.
Das ist ein Trauerspiel.
Das ist der Default, ja.
Im Rahmen der Privatisierung sind das jetzt sozusagen Daten in privater Hand und man kann die als Karte kaufen.
Apropos Straßenverzeichnis, es gibt auch kein offizielles Straßenverzeichnis einheitlich für ganz Deutschland. Das musst du auch irgendwie von den Ländern, manchmal von den Kommunen, einzeln manchmal kaufen, manchmal kostenlos kriegen. Gibt es über OpenStreetMap allerdings?
Achso, das haben wir gar nicht angesprochen im ganzen Ding, aber Föderalismus ist natürlich ein riesen Thema. 16 unterschiedliche Bundesländer, 16 unterschiedliche Regelungen, wie sie mit ihren Daten umgehen.
Und dann 16 verschiedene Software, dass alles gar nicht miteinander zu verbinden ist, die Daten.
Dann gibt es hier im Bundesamt noch Städte, die alle auch andere Systeme haben.
Okay, aber wir sind jetzt am Ende der Sendung, damit sollten wir nicht enden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das klingt alles sehr, so Obdachlosigkeit, Föderalismus, das ist fürchterlich.
Dann möchte ich gerne noch was Positives dazu sagen, wir Deutschen meckern immer gerne auf hohem Niveau und zwar egal, wie hoch das Niveau ist, klar im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern sind wir ganz sicher nicht an der Spitze, aber es gibt auch Länder, mit denen wir uns vergleichen könnten, da sind wir sehr, sehr viel besser. Es gibt Länder, in denen du nicht mal vertrauen kannst, wie viele Leute im Land leben. Sowas haben wir, wir können auch prinzipiell irgendwie unserem Bruttoinlandsprodukt halbwegs vertrauen, wenn wir wissen, wie es berechnet wird. Also da muss man schon sagen, wir haben schon eine Grundversorgung, die okay ist und vor allem, was mir Hoffnung gibt, ist, es wird besser. Also die Stadt, in der ich studiert habe, hat jetzt jemanden, der sich für offene Daten einsetzt und die machen jetzt genau das, was mich im Studium nämlich so aufgeregt hat, die befreien jetzt Daten. Finde ich super.
Ist da die Hoffnung sozusagen, dass das wegstirbt, das Personal, das...
So drastisch wollen wir ja nicht werden. Die werden alle reformiert, sie sehen das Licht.
Das ist schon spannend, weil das letztlich dazu führt, dass dieser Kampf zwischen Bevölkerung und den Behörden inzwischen sich ein bisschen verlagert hat in die Behörden selbst. Also es sind dann teilweise die Abteilungen, die miteinander jetzt streiten und die jüngeren Kollegen, die dafür sind, das offen zu legen und die älteren, die es nicht wollen. Und das ist ja schon mal ein Anfang.
Sehr gut. Freie Daten. Michael, ich würde dich noch mal kurz fragen, um noch mal auf diese Social-Bot-Nummer zurückzukommen. Und die Tatsache, dass das soziale Netzwerk unser Leben bestimmt und aber alle Daten, die wir daraus haben, eigentlich von denen zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Also es gibt diese API, aber alles, was daraus fällt, muss man denen quasi glauben. Gibt es, und also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es so ein, oder schwierig, vielleicht gar nicht die Motivation so hoch ist, aber gibt es Versuche, von außen diese Netzwerke so zu beobachten, dass man sagen kann, wir haben jetzt wirklich offene, vertrauenswürdige Daten, weil wir die selber gesammelt haben? Oder sind diese Dinge einfach zu groß dafür?
Na ja, also da müssen wir ein bisschen unterscheiden. Es gibt unterschiedliche soziale Netzwerke. Bei Twitter sieht es eigentlich ganz gut aus. Da kriegt man über die API im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, was ich auch über die normale Seite sehen kann. Ganz schlecht sieht es natürlich bei Facebook aus, weil denen klar ist, umso mehr Daten sie rausgehen, umso mehr können andere Leute mit ihnen konkurrieren im Prinzip. Denn das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook ist es, so viele Daten wie möglich zu sammeln. Und da sehe ich auch besonders die Schwierigkeit, dass extra oder besonders viele Leute bei Facebook sind, das heißt, wenn diese sozialen Netzwerke, durch was auch immer, für Effekte, irgendwie einen Einfluss auf unsere Gesellschaft haben, zum Beispiel in einer US-Wahl oder bei Brexit oder bei der Bundestagswahl, dass wir da als Gesellschaft gar nicht das Recht haben, da mal tiefer reinzuschauen und Forschung zu betreiben und das zu beobachten. Aber was war deine Frage?
Nice, du könntest bald in die Politik gehen. Die Frage war, ob es Bestrebungen gibt, ob man das von außen irgendwie so beobachtet, dass man die offenen Daten halt selber herstellt. Also im Prinzip Feinstaub-Messstationen ins Facebook reinhängen.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Da kann ich den Sensor liken?
Nein, es gibt ja das System der Datenspende. Bei Open Schufa holst du dir selbst Auskunft, beim Feinstaub hältst du dir so ein Sensor ins Zimmer. Und es gab ja zum Beispiel, das ist total versandet, Buzzfeed hatte glaube ich zur Bundestagswahl dieses Ding. Man konnte seinen eigenen Facebook-Code so ein bisschen verknüpfen und dann sollte das irgendwie hoch. Ich habe da nicht mehr davon gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie versandet ist. Aber gibt es so eine Bestrebung?
Es gab ein paralleles Projekt, das kenne ich von den Google-Suchergebnissen, um zu gucken, ob unterschiedliche Leute einfach unterschiedliche Google-Suchergebnisse bekommen, wenn sie sich über Parteien oder so etwas informieren. Da erinnere ich mich an das Ergebnis, dass dort keine großen Unterschiede waren, wie der aktuelle Stand bei Buzzfeed und Facebook ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe gesagt, vielleicht läuft das auch noch.
Würde ich aber begrüßen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also befreit Daten, befreit Algorithmen, befreit soziale Netzwerke. Kann man das so zusammenfassen, die Sendung?
Daten für alle.
Für die Bewegung zum runterladen für alle.
Sehr schön. Dann danke ich an dieser Stelle Michael Kreil, Kira Schacht und Arne Semsrott. Ich danke dem Publikum, dass sie hier wart. Und ich danke Daniel Moe für die Redaktion dieses Chaosradios, Moe und David für den Ton. Kamera hat Kai gemacht. Die News sind geschrieben von Moe und Helena und präsentiert von Christina. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst ihr nicht überwachen. Befreit eure Daten und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.